we got new merch some new colorways uh
in the be good to yourself collection
we've got hoodies in Plum and Moss we've
also got t-shirts in lilac moss and Blue
Mist hope you enjoy those those are good
colors
get that hitter and more at
theovinstore.com I'd also like to
announce some new tour dates I will be
coming with the return of the Rat tour
January 26th to Louisville Kentucky
January 28th Indianapolis
February 2nd Shreveport Louisiana
February 4th Baton Rouge March 24
Corpus Christi
March 25 Houston Texas April 26th
Phoenix down there in the Sun May 13th
New York City
and June 1st Austin Texas all those uh
shows go on sale Wednesday November 16th
at 10 A.M local time
with the code rat king that's the
pre-sale
um you can get any ticket through
theovan.com
t-o-u-r uh just make sure you go through
there to get accurately priced seats and
uh thank you guys and we love you
today's guest
um I mean this guy he's got more voices
in him than a dang schizophrenic you
know he's a real uh you know he just his
impersonations and his ability to
imagine and create at the same time it's
uh it's a remarkable gift to the world
and um and we've seen it through uh his
work on Saturday Night Live uh his
countless films
um Wayne's World his new podcast uh fly
on the wall with David Spade and his new
scripted podcast with Dex Carvey and
Julian matulich we're going to learn a
little bit about that today I'm grateful
to get to spend time with him Mr Dana
Carvey
[Music]
sit and tell you my story
[Music]
[Applause]
well the worst thing you can do is say
to yourself I wonder if I'll get an
erection
yeah
the whole idea of sex is not thinking
and all you have to do is concentrate on
turning yourself on
because they asked me that once on a
podcast so go how do you turn someone
else turn someone on you go turn
yourself on damn
true focus on that
yeah I think I I like yeah I mean I've
had probably libido issue since I was
probably
I would bet eight or nine months old I
don't know well but you're okay
you don't have a libido until you go
through puberty really right okay I mean
who has a libido when they're in diapers
but you know I don't know I have to look
at some pictures and see what you know
see what was going on back then but yeah
I felt like
I don't know when that libido starts
cranking up well it's normally I'll just
play doctor uh when puberty happens is
when libido kicks up I'm gonna say that
yeah we had a party in our neighborhood
this guy had an Elvis impersonator right
and he had a party for his child
whenever he went through puberty I
remember and we went out well that's
kind of like a bar mitzvah kind of right
I guess I don't know I'd never had never
been anything like that I think it was
like some part of I don't know if it was
like a church program or whatever but
yeah this fella got all pubescent or
whatever and so they invited everybody
over there for cake or whatever when I
turned 13 my dad headbutt me and I saw
Stars yeah you think you're a man
[Laughter]
dude that's the same thing bro I tell
everybody Mike Myers always said the one
movie movie had was a headbutt and you
always come up slow if you know there's
gonna be a fight like what's up we gotta
have peace boom and you really is
efficient didn't have that in Louisiana
head butts the sudden friendly one I
don't know Jed we should get along we
can share the fishing hole boom
I just I don't know where you grew up I
know it's down in that area of the world
yeah I think a good head but what was a
good good but oh mace I think was
popular by us are you a little warm
dinner well no I'm not well this this is
for Arctic weather but I just want to
keep the blue around me because it's hip
yeah it is I'm like in a little cozy
yeah I can't believe how good I look
today yeah that's amazing yeah isn't it
interesting someday you crack up you
wake up and you're like okay today's
gonna be an okay looking day I know well
if I go back I I still think that a man
and Lauren Michael said once something
about a man in his 40s and a woman in
their 20s they're both at the peak of
their power so you're just coming into
your Peak sex symbol you're successful
you're in your 40s now you go start to
look at 20 21
22. I'll keep going with 23. 24. but
yeah you're in you're in your private I
remember someone saying that to me I had
this guy my age doing my hair on some
kind of movie and he goes and I go I'm
38 you know and he goes oh you're in
your Prime ah that [ __ ] was right was
he no but I'm in my Prime now yeah yeah
the prime I guess I'm Johnny positive
the prime has to keep moving huh
uh you have to keep the prime moving
don't you the yeah if you if you didn't
age or get older then we'd be in some
kind of hellish environment you think
yeah we gotta check out we gotta have an
expiration date it makes everything
intense what if you lived a million
years you just you're just like what
would you do it's like I mean you would
definitely probably call in you know
you'd call you'd show up late to work
more
I think well you know I've always wanted
to play the saxophone because my parents
I got picked to play the saxophone in
fifth grade but it was seven dollars a
month and I kept coming to school it's
expensive huh and they said they said
where's your saxophone so I go I'll have
it tomorrow and at one point I think my
mom said you know we can't afford the
saxophone so if I lived a million years
I would spend at least 10 000 years
practicing a saxophone yeah bro you'd be
so good then you'd be able to play for
the king I don't think I no I don't
think that's my skill set but I like to
bang on things and strum things did you
have a uh instrument as a child was
there something you got kind of early
that they gave you usually a parent will
give a child something give them a horn
give them a little uh you know something
you see people right give them a
Moroccan that came later but first my
brother and I saw the Beach Boys we had
a band called The Surfers so we had the
clothes hamper you know where the crayon
we wrote the surface he got a one string
guitar he could play Louie Louie for a
buck and I would kick the clothes hamper
for my kick drum and then I had a Hardy
Boys book for my snare and the two
drumsticks we stole them from Mickey
Hart of the Grateful Dead his store in
the 1960s because we were huge juvenile
delinquents and then I met him 30 years
later and I didn't know if it was true
he goes did you own a music store on
Laurel Avenue in San Carlos he goes yeah
I think I shoplifted there I handed him
a 20. but I had that and then I got a
big bash snare drum in sixth grade
plastic but I had a muscly cousin who
came down it just beat killed it in a
day and why did he do it he just was
angry that you were gonna learn it he
was one of those muscly kids he's like a
sixth grader Jay winners he just was
muscly every you visited him every time
he visited me crouched like he was going
to wrestle you yeah you know one of
those cousins like I don't want to
wrestle you dude so he broke the big
bash but do you do you remember what
what toy blew your mind because I always
ask people this I this is what I say the
big three from five to twelve all right
movie or TV show where you went holy
[ __ ]
toy you had where you want holy [ __ ] and
then a bike where you felt like an
adventurer a bike you know
yeah I think the bike was uh it had
those spoke things those little things
those little things whenever the wheel
turned like the little thing would slide
down a little it had like a little a
little you know a thing that they used
to count if you can't count real good
and you slide it oh okay so they had
like a little ticker thing
yeah yeah something like a little like
these little he pull it up Zach Abacus
no can you pull up what I'm talking
about just like that this because we
would do a clothespin and playing cards
to get the motorcycle you did that too
right yeah they yeah we got up sold some
garbage a little deal but it would take
and then this hot girl sometimes would
ride on it with me you know or not that
hot but like you know she like lived
near me which was hot back then you know
yeah dude if a girl lived far and if you
could throw something and hit a girl
damn she was fine
when you were growing up I would say in
third grade yeah did you ever drop your
pencil
so you had to pick it up and then you
look behind you and the girl you could
see the girl's skirt oh drop it so she
would get it no drop it so you have an
excuse to reach down and look back where
the girl you like is sitting yeah dude I
was erect from probably wait a minute
you had no libido oh I don't know if I
did it I might have been all libido but
I was a wreck probably uh from me I
can't even imagine I think from probably
fifth grade to probably
31. would you ever have it like in grade
school like okay and you're just full
bloom you're just fantasizing you're in
a Zone you're not paying attention they
go Theo come to the chalkboard come to
the chalkboard right now yeah you're
like and you had a full erection what
did you do about that joust I would
joust the other guy passing me in the
aisle that's what I would do everybody
was in wreck man it was just a whole
classroom oh it was a bunch of like
those tarpons passing each other in the
water and in uh in Middle School in
junior high man every like I feel like
you just didn't want to get snagged on
somebody's freaking pants now when
you're walking down the hall I remember
sometimes I would have my strap hanging
off my back and we had hooked on
somebody else's penis I was just you
know because in junior high every kid is
just so damn erect bro uh it's just like
you you know people just they can't
handle it you know you get that front
Rudder on you and you can't handle it as
a child but I remember this hot girl got
her toe caught in my bike yeah we had to
take her to the like I don't know if it
was an emergency room or just just
somebody close by that had damn thread
on them you know and we took her over
there and uh I remember damn thread you
mean just cool clothes oh no like just
like could knit Knitter oh you know
Spruce splicer toe back up oh and so uh
I remember she got man she got she got
pretty mangled up and but she had a limp
after that and I would I'd limp with it
because she's always trying to run away
from me so after that it was kind of
good because it kind of you know gave me
a chance so she's out in some open field
in Louisiana and she's got this hickety
step because of a broken leg and you're
kind of chasing her and she's trying to
Get Away originally she'd keep away from
me but once she got her too she rode on
my bike one time she got her toe caught
in the spokes and that was enough
permanent damage it would cause at least
maybe two months of damage wow okay God
well my brother lost his front teeth
two different ways in fifth grade I
think first he did a wheelie on his
Stingray front tire went boom chip they
got the Caps then he's doing Duncan
yo-yos and he's going loop-de-loop bam
shipped him again
only twice I thought there'd be a third
one man it'll happen still Duncan
Imperials I went shoplifted six of those
at a Woolworths I would go to kids on
the street go you want a yo-yo and I go
in steal a yo-yo bring it out you want
one Duncan Imperial go in take it I was
juvenile in fourth grade yeah and what
were you think you were acting out about
something I'm sitting here with Dana
Carvey as well and I'm sorry I didn't
even introduce that not at all and what
is that is Dana short for something Dana
no my name was Brett on the birth
certificate my grandmother because I had
three older brothers we were all stacked
tight five kids in 10 years my mom
um and my grandmother said they're gonna
call him Brett the brat
so I think Dana Andrews was a movie star
at the time I think it came from that
but it was I got in girls P's PE classes
in high school like the thing would come
report to the girls physical education
class because they couldn't show up yeah
Theo is definitely a man's name but
Dana's a switch hitter like Chris or
Robin yeah Robin was a wild one now Dana
but yeah that must have been nice I was
thinking yeah could it be short for
something maybe maybe bandana I could
see
uh they call me Dane the brain because
my two of my brothers were dyslexic so
they got C's if they really tried so I
got a few bees and then I was my
nickname was day in the brain oh yeah if
you were that's kind of funny if you're
even smarter than your brother you get
classified as the brain even if all
y'all are dumb
yeah not y'all but I'm just saying no
just in any family you know like this is
our smart kid you know we get C's well
it was it was it was bad for dyslexic
kids in those days because they just put
you in the the yellow book or the red
reading book oh then there was the green
pretty smart we got in the blue book we
were the rock stars and then they would
send us to the speed reading kind of
Clockwork Orange van and they would do
the words like that we're eating a
thousand words a minute so that was you
know it was a weird childhood but I my
brothers were we're all shoppers
shoplifters and smokers we would steal
my mom's Kent cigarettes and just whale
on those then we would eat ice plants so
no one would smell it on our breath
and one day we went to the mall and we
three of us me and my two older brothers
we parked our bikes said [ __ ] someone's
gonna steal them we went into a hardware
store stole locks locked up our bikes
went back in shoplifted came home laid
everything out on the table my brother
Brad who I based Garth on a science
brother he added it all up and he goes
That's 14 and about 92 cents of stuff in
those days so that so therefore we said
14.92 it's like Columbus so when you
were shoplifting with your brother you'd
go are you sailing the blue he goes yeah
I'm sailing the blue I'm trying to get
you know and my brother Brad eventually
uh would steal for the sport of it like
he'd go and get a whole LP album under
his shirt and I go up you see it sail in
the blue and he goes check it out I
could I could take it if I want I could
take it because you talked like that and
then he would put it back so he was like
a catch and release shoplifter wow you
don't see a lot of that no just for
sport just for but he was a brilliant
kid I mean we would go to Battle Creek
Michigan to get something from Kellogg's
you know the the cereal so you you'd
have to put a quarter in the envelope
and he would just he tore a little part
in the envelope open to see if they go
oh poor kid if someone tore it and he
would get the prize or if we wanted to
buy candy at the Mercantile when we went
to the lake he would have a he would
sort of take a piece of metal and make a
slug out of it and put a quarter on top
so the guy would think it was 50 cents
so he was clever kid dang yeah real
clever huh it sounds like he's very I
have that Ocean's 11 in him you know
like he's got that yeah uh and did he
end up getting in any any real crime
no he just he became he became a
brilliant engineer he invented the first
sort of sort of uh online or sorry
computer video home thing was called The
Video Toaster with Tim Jenison in the
90s and he was the kid who
um had D cell batteries I found a frog
one day and I gave I thought it was dead
you know and he kind of hooked it up and
it was sort of vibrating because he he
had these two details and he sort of
wired it up on it and I thought it was
kind of I was opening and uh I said Brad
the eyes opened it and this is a true
story I do it in my ACT but he's like
cars he said yeah I brought him back to
life he'll never die again that was a
but Scott and I so he was the one the
bunk bed one and we were because y'all
shared y'all at a room with how many
bunk beds in it the downstairs brothers
that were weird even to this day they
had a bunk bed downstairs Two Brothers
Two Brothers and me and Scott up there
mark and Brad and Mark would wet the bed
like anybody's business so my parents
got this machine in a catalog so it'd be
like this plastic sheet and a little
mechanical thing to would wake him up
when he'd start to wet the bed yeah so
he starts to wet one night but he wet so
much he he killed the machine and that
would rain down on Brad because he was
the lower bump but he was inventing all
kinds of stuff but and then Scott and I
we were upstairs and uh he would sleep
with the covers over but we was a rough
and tumble second day baked goods you
know you go to the my mom and girls
bakery one day old too too expensive two
day old they're almost giving it away
yeah so we put those in a freezer my dad
would buy a side of cheap cheap beef and
he would put it in this freezer and then
we'd get it and it was almost all
Gristle
it goes oh Jesus Christ the best parts
of gristle and it was just like gnarly
steak so I had a blocked artery by the
time I was your age yeah yeah 100
blocked man it was really blocked there
was so much fight I I think like
there was so much more mystery and stuff
it seems like when you look at like your
childhood right yeah and then you have
children now how many children do you
have two
okay and you have two male children that
I know of Sir right and so y'all are
male heavy y'all seed line is male heavy
yeah basically they're my younger sister
my mom had four boys I've had two boys
yeah so a lot of you know I think of
masculinity begets masculinity no I'm
just saying it's almost like a damn gay
Nightclub at this point I mean I'm
saying there's a lot of men in it that's
all I'm saying dude but why is it a cake
you're gonna have a lot of men over
there you know well you're saying
Jeffrey Dahmer would buy all a couple
sandwiches well there was a lot of
wrestling so my dad first of all he
loved to grow a scratchy beard and then
you go oh Jesus Christ time for the
whiskers and you're like five years old
you weigh like 40 pounds ah and he would
get on top of you and he go whiskers and
he would just rub his face on your face
like ah yeah and then he'd have me oh
Jesus Christ fight him so I had to fight
my brother Scott who seemed like a giant
compared to me he was 12 I was 10. and
he'd go oh grab his balls he would
scream at us your dad oh Jesus Christ
grab his balls so that was these are
these are the good times Theo oh yeah
but I know I I had a Disney face when I
was your age so people always used to
think what up what a mellow easy happy
life you've had but it was it was good
that we had each other right and so it
sounds like it sounds like y'all were
really close huh we are we are still now
we survived it it was a fascinating time
it was you know but um you look back on
your childhood pretty fondly it sounds
like you look back on because you have
so many like Memories I love I'm like
kind of fascinated by Nostalgia and
stuff so I think I think about those
times a lot you know well I think that
those years you can't ever get back and
those years are precious the thing that
we were able to do is we were so
independent there was one landline it
was a party line sometimes you pick it
up and the neighbors are using it oh
sorry yeah
so you were just gone a lot and my dad
would go to Montana with his friends a
lot and so we would be just on our own
and just on get on your Schwinn Stingray
my brother got the Schwinn monster green
my parents ran out of money they got me
this Sears offload or whatever it was it
was a cheap kickoff for one which I knew
it was okay but a step kid or whatever
the bike was even called
the other Scott was the favorite so we
uh we just ride around all day and we
just you know I played flag football in
fifth grade and it seemed like
professional sports yeah I loved it
ready break and I was the half back and
you know so I agree with you that's why
I call them the seminal years I think
they're so important
to about 12. and that then then life
kind of interrupts but before that
you're taking in so much information you
know what about you yeah we had a decent
time seven or eight what's going on in
your household are you scared dude I was
very scared growing up I think I think I
just grew up like real sense like super
sensitive real scared uh
um
what what was it like I think uh yeah
it's a lot of time alone a lot of time
with strange babysitters you know we had
a babysitter that got a roach in her ear
one night and she kept like yelling at
us that she had a roach in here but she
spoke also Spanish or something or I
don't know if she spoke Spanish or just
something was like wrong with her or
something or she didn't maybe she didn't
speak real well or something but we
thought it was Spanish you know yeah
babysitters are memorable we had one
when I was five my parents drove to
Montana and so lived in Montana growing
up no just till age five but we went
there every summer I was just there so
I'm I'm a Native Son in a sense but that
babysitter like I'm five and I gotta
she's putting Bactine in a Band-Aid on
my knee and I'm five and I'm remembering
her years later like she was a fairy
princess like gorgeous so I said my
brothers at the time Mark was like 12
and he goes oh yes she was just a
complete knockout but that's that was a
memory when I was five but I wasn't
thinking sexually I just thought I just
hit my brain you know you know I've lost
some of my hair
um I wasn't taking care of myself and I
got off my medications uh I help you
keep your hair
and damn a third of it fell out
so that's what's happening in the world
you know two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they are 35
more than 50 million men in the U.S
suffer from male pattern baldness
one thing you can do is what I'm back
doing now is using keeps
keeps offers a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair I'm
not worried anymore I know I'm back on
the right path
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to receive your
first month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash t-h-e-o to get your
first month free keeps.com slash Theo
this holiday season the best deal in
Wireless can only be found at mint
mobile
right now when you switch to Mint mobile
and buy any three month plan
you get another three months for free
that's right all plans come with
unlimited talk and text and high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G network switch to Mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month for a limited time
only buy any three month mint Mobile
plan and get three more months free by
going to mintmobile.com Theo
that's mintmobile.com Theo cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Theo
yeah there were babysitters oh
babysitters were good but ours was yeah
this one lady she was either Spanish or
dis I don't know she had like she might
have just had like
um
[ __ ] she could have been named
narcoleptic I don't know what she was
there was something unique about her to
us you know yeah
um and she um
she got a roach in her ear and she was
trying to tell us and we're just kids
you know I remember and she's like
yelling in Spanish about her having like
a uh in
um
I don't know what they call it she's
yelling at the kids Allison we don't
know we don't know what's going on we
you know we don't know if it's like
charades I remember we barely knew her
you know and then uh she ended up having
to go to the hospital and she did a
roach had got into her ear God it's
funny because that's such a great word
for that accent because I remember Al
Pacino doing a Cuban accent
is a great word
sorry am I canceled can't do that
actually good dude so yeah so I just for
a second because my father was
Nicaraguan also so you're scared to do
that here so he had a full accent and
everything he had probably I would say
40 accent so you would say you know I
don't know the different I just know a
general I just know Al Pacino's crazy
Cuban XO why are you going to talk it's
time for Thanksgiving dinner still is
that how he said it no he didn't not
that much he's a little lighter you know
good deal yeah
so what did he think of you you think
like my dad had it in for me a little
bit he was he jealous of you think yeah
he was jealous that you were kind of
like PRI like funny and fun he didn't
think I was funny I think my brother
Brad could fix things like oh you know
our tool drawer was really sucked like
the hammer always was lost so Brad would
take a butter knife and fix the dryer
and my dad would stand over him and then
try to take credit for it he was just
insecure about not being able to do that
and then for me it's because my mom
called me precious I look kind of
androgynous I don't know what he thought
I was but yeah I could see it a little
and he was well I definitely had a very
bunch of baby face and he had it in for
him but what did your dad think of you
were you the favorite son or you how
many brothers I had one brother and two
sisters okay and my dad was born in 1910
so he was an old man right so by the
time you were like eight or ten he was
almost 80 then yeah he was almost 80s
when I was 10 he was 80 and so
it was interesting I don't think I knew
what he thought of you know he would be
sleeping a lot like a lot of my memories
or my mom waking him up and him being
kind of pissed off about stuff or he'd
be sitting somewhere and he would just
kind of doze off you know he liked to
let me sometimes like rub on his
shoulders a little bit
um sometimes he would smell like beer
um he let me like drive his car whenever
I could like was tall enough to drive
like he kind of like let me just he
needed help you know a little bit so it
was like kind of like this trade-off a
little but what did he think he thought
he's got three other kids yeah I mean in
in between him and your mom I mean who
what was there anyone who was the
clear-cut favorite or I was my mom's
favorite and Scott was my dad's favorite
because all of a sudden you'd come home
he has a new guitar like it's not even
Christmas or his birthday [ __ ] that's
way unfair oh man but I I was not
envious of it to be to be Bud's favorite
no I didn't I just got didn't you know
that was great get away for the monster
but I thought he's just getting toys he
was called Scotchman or Scott the pot oh
he got it did you have a nickname Theo
De Leo no I think got his head like Theo
uh what is it Teddy maybe sometimes did
they so why did they name you Theo it's
such a unique name isn't it for that
your generation yeah my dad his name was
yeah oh so he had this thing you know
like some type of uh Spanish Flair or
something you know
[Laughter]
I just think you must have been such a
cool kid because you have such a curious
brain so I I hope that you're what about
your mom didn't think I think they
didn't my mom was busy working so we had
these strange people that'd be over
there you know a lot of these
babysitters and we'd make up stories and
tell them stuff you know and a lot of
them we'd have like it was the first
we'd have like this big black lady that
would take care of us or a very old
woman that would take care of us and
just like we had the Spanish lady with
the roach and her you know like so there
was just like I think we didn't really
know who was gonna be there one time we
did get the hot chick dude I remember
she took me to Summer campers day camp
at the YMCA and she drove this orange
car I don't remember and she played Bon
Jovi and I just remember I don't think
I'd ever heard music until there was
like a hot woman pregnant oh yeah and
suddenly like I could hear music I was
cool and I was like Play it Again Play
it again and like just like her like
interacting with me or engaging with me
was like the most magical thing I
remember and then
um yeah and she was not even cute I
don't think but I thought she was like
just the hottest thing ever you know
they're you know it's like a man
actually
she was almost like a man she Lo she had
like a short haircut and she she kind of
thinks she kind of I think a lot of
dudes would have been like whoa you know
she's not my first choice of a woman you
know that crushes I had just mad crushes
with absolute shyness uh Linda Benson
there was like uh she had some tits huh
seventh grade party and you do a makeout
session you know in the dark and it was
Linda Benson and she knew it who her way
around that situation but I went what
did they do they put you all in a closet
or something this is a dark room and I
you know seventh grade and like what and
suddenly yeah maybe we went in a closet
yeah I don't know but uh and what
happened is it like the hardest part
ever was I think trying to touch a
breast or something at the movies a lot
of guys there'd be big guys be like
touch it get that titty boy and they
threaten you if you didn't do it you
know so then you're like working off of
a clock kind of as like a shot clock
well the thing is is that there were I
don't know where you were in junior high
there's some women that go right they
come back from the summertime and
they've been genetically gifted they're
suddenly stunning some of the guys we
had a guy who's like had a little beard
he was all muscle he was in eighth grade
and I look like a fetus with shoes I
mean I was nothing was happening but I
you know I was uh I got a chip on my
shoulder and you it I don't know where
my drive comes from a little bit but I
hate to lose and I hate anyone trying to
[ __ ] with me but I mostly want to be
nice and friendly and stuff but if
someone goes I'm not good with that I I
attack pretty hard not physically but I
will you know verbally you'll be you'll
get that I have to get the upper hand
but Spade's got he's got an edge to him
too you know what that's like my good
buddy Spade yeah we had a nice time we
had dinner the other night that was we
ended up laughing our ass off about your
comedy team
Australian uh
dancers in Vegas you know your movie
idea that they try to go to Vegas and
become like Thunder Down Under like oh
yeah like models with their shirts off
but they call this house
on caulk he's bounced together with
cocaine bios and then they have a little
bit you know it only lasts like one it's
only for 30 seconds of the movie but uh
that was just funny but yeah space I
think we you know it's like he's fun you
guys have your podcast right it's called
Flying the wall fly on the wall uh it's
called fly on the wall uh it's a
promotion yeah David known him since
before SNL met him when he came in he
was always cool you met him before that
yeah he was like 21 I was like 30 or
something and did you guys seem did he
seem similar to you kind of
um there was a period of time where yeah
he was like definitely from My Tribe you
know we have us you know there's there
was a time when he opened for me so he's
like 28 29 I'm like 38 and we he'd come
out and we were playing these sheds in
in the round in the Northeast and he'd
walk out and they'd go from a lot wide
shot at that point they thought it was
me you know and so but they're like no
no Spade was so hip even then eventually
he just had shorts on his skateboard and
he would kind of just hang over the
stool and he's like what's up everybody
you can do it that way I didn't know you
could do with that way and he was
hysterical because I come out jumping
around in that special I was in front of
that you know I drenched in sweat in
this page it's cool he's got a little
Diet Pepsi what's up ladies you know
yeah so he's the coolest but really fun
to do a podcast with him he can drop a
little sketch in five seconds
he can go he can take a story of just
that the hamburger was overcooked the
guy's going I'm like
hey buddy could you a little bit on the
boat I mean he'll create a complete
sketch in five seconds so it's so much
fun to watch it's so Lo-Fi he doesn't
push it at all and you got to go back
and Rewind it almost
yeah yeah that's a remarkable way to say
him it's like he like just he's not out
there barking about his Bears it's just
like hey come see what I made he's got
this little physical moves that's that
represent another person a little effect
and really funny word packages hey buddy
foreign
you know
that was I learned that from John the
winters you know then the rotary dial
went out and I lost my closer oh that's
the worst
that's the worst one time
when time start to change yeah I know
isn't it weird about humor do you find
this Dana that I like I get scared that
I don't know what the next generation of
humor is because it's almost impossible
to really know it because you have to
like live you have to come up in it
really yeah I know it's really
interesting I mean obviously I don't
generally now go east you know I don't
do Indian accents or Japanese accents
really I can do them you know
um and I had a bit about them and I just
sort of dropped it I don't know it's
there's this sensitivity now but I do
agree with Bill Burr he was on our
podcast flying the wall and that if the
intent is to hurt is different than just
an observation yeah you know I just was
talking about where maybe the dialect of
a Japanese accent came from just did
every accent like French is
where did that come from you know and
where did you know
look at that and I figured is because of
all the ring of fire all the earthquakes
so you're just sitting around
you know so that was that so I don't
know if you'll have to edit that out but
I just thought it's funny
I mean so because why do they talk like
that they couldn't talk like this yeah
everybody could have talked like this
all humans all humanoids were just just
grunting all over the world pointing and
running
and then the sounds came up
you know and I think the Indian was more
copacetic on the trade routes yeah
foreign
and then we would ask him you know
[Music]
it's incredible accents it's crazy to
think that somebody has a whole
different like like Bible of what is
sounds and thoughts inside oh I love it
and I'm just into rhythms that's all you
know they the whole is greater than some
of the parts and when I hear
I just like it's just poetry to me you
know with any accent well it makes me
think to what their thoughts and insides
are like you know and what some of the
mechanics are like inside of it you know
that's what I wonder sometimes and where
does it come from emotionally uh for the
male and the female Dynamic yeah because
yeah like just like a lot of asian
females are very yeah
and the men are kind of alpha male which
you can sort of practice probably
lowering your voice yeah it's coming
from you know like I see it's almost
where semen launches from like right
there you know a little bit
[Music]
yeah that could be a guy ordering a
Pepsi
this is my favorite podcast ever I'm
just saying this I think there's this
guy ordering Pepsi yeah exactly or a guy
having a male orgasm yeah and they don't
have a lot of orgasms also in Japan and
in uh we're orgasm heavy over here I
mean we're skeeting up the landscape you
know and then wait a minute we're orgasm
heavy we're skeeting up the landscape so
in Europe like so
we we climax more than Japanese people
or Asian people or any other culture by
far because we are the world literally
yeah we are the world you know we're
we're in that video
no but I could do I could do a spring
scene if you want we are the world I'm
Bruce Springsteen I'm five foot seven a
good day but with my boots and my cowboy
hat it's six feet of Springsteen coming
at you sure I could have fixed my under
Bible why I'm worth a billion dollars
and I love everybody so anyway that's uh
what were we saying we uh I just made
all the badass people in the world came
to America all the aggressive people are
that's why right we are so Freedom heavy
here if they told the anti-vaxxers we're
not going to admonish you we're not
going to say you're a piece of [ __ ] and
You're a murderer but could you please
get a vaccine they would have been
unsure man just ask me yeah but if you
go you got to get one [ __ ] you man
America no one tells me what to do so
it's just the wrong strategy yeah you
know Arnold did a PSA it should have
been instead of you know [ __ ] you
Freedom it should have been you know if
you could look like they didn't know you
could maybe go to the doctor you get the
little injection you know when you help
out the people and instead of you moved
around but we are badasses we're the
people you know my ancestors just
somebody at some point in Ireland just
said I think I'm leaving yeah oh I'm out
there where are you going I don't want
to stay here in the rain in the potatoes
I'm going to America you could get
killed I don't give a [ __ ] yeah you know
we'll have a better menu so where you
have Nicaraguan polish and Nicaraguan
yeah so somebody probably [ __ ] on a
boat I'm guessing because I don't know
how you even get that mix you know but
that's a steamroller that went through
the Suez Canal and somehow connected
your mom and dad I don't know it was a
probably a 100 ton Steamroller
I don't know but I think look man I got
I want to go back to this guy I think
we're seeming heavy over here right okay
so you mean we have a lot of semen or we
climax we climax a lot here I believe in
America because we're we're selling it
now there's you know there's a lot of
and I know there's Japanese porn and
stuff but in Japan like even if you go
there it's hard to meet women there's
not as much I don't think promiscuous
sex
um from what I've heard anyway well look
I don't know like for me as a kid you'd
go to the dump
or go in a park and jerk off no you'd
find a beat up Playboy magazine oh yeah
and I don't understand I can't even wrap
my mind around a 12 year old online
going on porn yeah I don't know what
what toxicity or joy that represents but
the boys are falling behind the
educational system so technology gave
Boys video games you know and porn and
then said now study your algebra yeah uh
I think I got something better to do
yeah you know I'm about to find the
square of my own route
at least he had a smart answer totally
dead I'm gonna do it so it's uh the boys
are behind now the this is the it's been
the year of the woman for the last 30
years which I'm okay with but here we
are again in 2023 it is drum roll year
of the woman again and so it's a great
time to be a woman and I'm all for it
it's just the boys have been the porn
and the video games are been really beat
down
yeah did you ever tail end that did you
were you in a Nintendo yeah we got
Nintendo came out I remember when we get
a game on our birthday usually you'd get
a game and your friend would come over
to see what game it was you had that one
gift and you'd open it and and when porn
came along man I remember yeah I would
bike far for porn if I heard there was
porn somewhere you know I was starved I
was starved for like a fat from like for
motherly affection so I think when porn
came around it really started to fulfill
some of that space let me let me just
unpack that for a minute because I was a
therapist for a prepared time we really
I'm not no but I I love
talking about human age so what do you
mean you were starved for affection your
mom didn't give you affection yeah I
think my mom didn't like look at me much
you know she didn't
did she she didn't pick me up much no no
I had a sister that was real sick that
had uh she was born with like a rare
liver condition and so she is different
than the rest of my siblings because she
got actually like physically picked up
but my mom didn't she doesn't know that
there's like this emotional world at all
I think she just probably didn't get it
you know I don't know if I got a lot of
it either I mean maybe it was the 60s I
you know I don't remember
you know I love you but she was nice she
was sweet but she was the sixth kid she
was as terrified of my dad we all were
you know but oh your mom was oh wow yeah
but she wasn't mean she was sweet but uh
she was terrified we were all aware it
was just like you know this one time I
got up uh these are just fun stories I
got up and uh you know I was like four
or five and there was no toilet paper I
had you know and so I used the towel and
I was so young I just put it back on the
rack so to wipe my butt and my dad came
out with it yeah and then I had to grab
my ankles in front of everybody and he
had asked my brothers how many
oh you had to go get his belt need to
snap it
you had to go grab it you had to go get
it you get the belt and then he would
snap it and you'd grab your ankles and
then he'd ask your brothers how many all
right so then your brothers get the time
yeah give him four four and then he
would just start screaming yeah
so the next day I I had short-term
memory issues I wiped my ass again with
a towel in his bathroom and I put it
back on the rack no I didn't do it a
second time I didn't do it
but I wanted to tell you about my toys
because we didn't have I came up during
so-called practical effects like we got
Rock'em sock'em robots there was nothing
visual on a TV screen rocking talking
robots was amazing getaway Chase game
and we played a lot of board games yeah
it was you know they're kind of cool
don't you find the tactile
three-dimensional board Stratego or uh
risk they're playing risk Candyland we
play we played a lot of games Scrabble
we played a lot I remember my favorite
time actually as a kid was when the
power would go out because our family
had to all get together you know it was
like we had to be kind of stuck in the
same room because we needed like right
you know Mom had two candles or whatever
and so we have to go downstairs and so
and you couldn't really fight because if
you if you fought and ran off out of the
distance of the Candlelight it was real
scary so yeah power outages were hip
everybody had to like kind of needed
each other you know so it was like yeah
there was I used to kind of like hope
that the power would go out because it
would give me a time where
I don't know I just really like those
moments where
um we all it was like the only time I
felt like our family there was a
semblance of that we needed each other
you know yeah it's interesting I I do
know that the visceral feeling of like
you kind of say you're not feeling well
can't go to school
and then you had the house to yourself
all day because my mom taught preschool
and you're watching anybody can teach
preschool no offense your mom I'm sure
she was awesome no she was yeah my
sister became a preschool teacher but
being a house by yourself and then
looking out the window at like three
o'clock and seeing the kids who went to
school his little Melancholy I was
almost like a panic attack like I should
have gone oh yeah and it's it's like
when school was canceled you find out
that there's no school today because of
whatever reason all those feelings same
thing with the powers out you know and
you know the all these things again they
they inform us that's what my five years
of therapy was about all those
experiences and how they stay with you
you know and how it manifests in you now
yeah you know it's interesting how it
does it was your so did your did you and
your dad have a good relationship
because it sounds like I think a lot of
men from his era probably just had a
tougher I think that it was a different
thing of being a man back then it was
full John Wayne [ __ ] and he was so
terrified of his son not being you know
and he was an orphan and he went through
different you know and then he got in
the Navy in 1943 or something or the
Army now he's an orphan with a gun now
he's while he was a radio operator in
India but I'm sure he had a firearm at
some point but it was it was a different
time and you know sometimes I would pick
up the phone at night I'd hear his birth
mother saying you forgive me buddy
because he was nickname was Bud for
giving him up at Birth you know so he
had his he was wounded and had that
deep-seated insecurity I think he had a
little
colorblind and a little dyslexic stuff
that would have not been diagnosed so he
had an inferiority complex but I you
know in the end of the day I don't
Harbor any I mean I'm kind of like you
know just moving on I mean but but there
were times there was a few times I felt
like he was being intentionally cruel to
me and getting off on it you know
because when all my brothers left I was
the last one to focus on and I'm with my
two High School buddies cross country
Runners really close friends all we did
was run and I was gonna work this weed
killer and spray it around the yard so
he came in the garage to go
um how do I get the top of this off Dad
and he goes this is with a quote my
friends never forgot it oh Jesus Christ
use your penis you [ __ ]
zombie bro that use your penis your
[ __ ] you know it's like okay it's
practical advice I am a [ __ ] I don't
know how to do it can I use my penis so
I started no but that but then he kind
of it was real anger and my friends
laugh it it freaked them out and six
weeks later I got out of there I thought
this is not good use your penis you
[ __ ] it's a poetry to it you know we
all laughed a lot now I mean we we
laughed even then we just have fits of
laughter dude laughter was so there used
to be a value to the moment you know and
I think about this a lot that there used
to be like the moment was so valuable
because you couldn't there wasn't a lot
of recording of it there wasn't nobody
had the opportunity to see it again a
million times over it was like this is
the freaking moment are you gonna be
here right now just go and you know what
I've observed is like young women are
the happiest people on Earth really
because I go to Griffith Park and I got
my sweatshirt hood on I'm gone I'll see
groups of high school or call these
girls
laughing and chirping and just like and
I'm just like you know it's like just
giggling just head back laughing but we
did so much of that that's what made me
a comedian the friends I had there's
such they were just really funny I had
great sense of humor and we just just
started performing just laughing
laughing laughing and you know sometimes
you lose that but it's so fun to laugh
like on this scripted podcast
we had a uh we don't have to bring it up
but no let's bring it up I want to yes
but we had a credit role and Dex my son
Dex Carvey and Julia madelage did so
many things it was during the pandemic
they they wore every hat they're
directing producing so the credit roll
at the end I read it as a character but
they did so many things that it just hit
me like a ton of bricks and it wasn't
one of the hardest I've laughed in the
last five years there's a character like
this co-directed by Julian mattelich
index coffee written by Dex coffee and
Julian matulich edited by dexa and it
went on and on but they literally had to
wear all those hats in the pandemic we
just did it at a table with a laptop but
that belly laughing is so valuable and
so charming and you're right just just
going with it we had a little bit the
other night right before that last 10
minutes I was really because it just
getting silly you were interested
oh I'm cork yeah what was it yeah what
was it we were talking about having like
an Australian it was like the Thunder
from Down yeah Thunder from Down Under
your two characters and you're the the
Spade would be the guy yeah you're like
it's a 2 p.m little review and you'd be
in Speedos and so you decided you spell
it differently than [ __ ] and balls but
basically on [ __ ] ease balls together
we're killing bows and then you start
dancing yeah just to see Spade do that
would be pretty funny and especially if
one of them lost his [ __ ] and he is only
balls you know and that's why they had
to do it
wouldn't that be crazy oh I'm I'm not a
cop car I'm only bolt he's only [ __ ]
together we're only balls and only [ __ ]
sign on to www dot only [ __ ]
onlybowls.com yeah that's anyway I want
to say [ __ ] and balls more on this
bucket and there's any other one
he's talking on with Bowser but it's
just idiots with super cocky that's the
funny part yeah we are here we come
watch us come see your penises Outside
Inside
[Laughter]
when I was a kid once the guy next door
was mowing the lawn and screaming and he
cut off some of his toes right but the
ambulance got him but the toe was out
there later yeah so then my brother Brad
came out and put it in formaldehyde my
mom saw it and said we got to take it we
got to get to the you know take him to
the place and they went into like a
medical center we just moved to this
town and she went into a psychiatrist's
office and she goes there's a boy who's
missing a toe in my car you know they
said it's okay lady just have a seat you
know but Brad's kept that big toe and I
remember looking at it you know wow yeah
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
I want to let you know that um there's
nothing wrong with getting help
you know I see therapists all the time
and
and I've had experiences where
I just couldn't make it through my day
you know I couldn't make it through the
damn hour I've had those experiences
um
and I don't do it alone anymore
better help
can help you as the world's largest
therapy service better help us match
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
a hundred percent online plus it's
affordable no waiting rooms no traffic
no endless searching for the right
therapist just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler and I like to remind
people that if you don't think your
therapist is working it's not
challenging you
make a switch try another one you can
always come back you can always try
someone new but don't sit there and
continue to go to the same therapist if
you don't feel it's being effective
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash t-h-e-o It's the Most
Wonderful Time of the Year
it's also the most hectic time
you know it's a time when the traffic
starts to jam up and you're leaving out
of here out of hot chocolate Avenue and
trying to get over to brisket drive over
there to be at a family function and you
gotta damn stop at a CVS to get a dang
lipstick or something for somebody
what I'm telling you is ship station is
here to help when you're buried in
orders and emails from stressed
customers
You'll wish you had ship station
ship station helps you figure it all out
helps you manage your e-commerce get
your orders out easy ship station works
with all your favorite places to sell
online including eBay Shopify Amazon
Etsy
manage every order from one simple
dashboard
print shipping labels and easily compare
rates and delivery times and when you
sign up for ship station using my promo
code you'll even get two months to try
it free over a hundred and thirty
thousand companies have grown their
e-commerce business with ship station
and 98 of companies that stick with ship
station for a year become customers for
life this holiday season give yourself
the gift of stress free holiday shipping
use promo code Theo today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's
shipstation.com promo code t-h-e-o yeah
I remember we found two fingers in the
woods one sound like a peace sign really
yeah and we were actually collecting
cans and we found two fingers in the
wood in the woods what else happened did
you grow up in is it suburb or rural it
was rural but it wasn't redneck so I
never had like any redneck stuff we just
had like a lot of poor people like we to
watch dogs give birth and people would
bet on how many whelping how much dogs
how many babies were going to be in it
um yeah we grew up like a hamster
breeding area we had a dude not far from
us I used to breed hamsters you know it
was big in our area we had
um
I used to clean out wishing wells Our
Town had like apparently the most
wishing wells per capita or something is
that because of religiosity or just
irishness I guess or I think people just
love you know
people just love having water hidden
under the land I tell you for me
personally when I had this uh this
bypass at 42 I'm incredible now no but
uh you had a crowd droop uh yeah you
know a double yeah well the heart's
perfect but the artery was blocked damn
and I had to do a bob bypass and they
did it they didn't do the right artery
but they didn't harm me but it was fine
but my Indian cardiologist PK Shaw did
uh he went to Mother Teresa's gravesite
and did a prayer for me and then my
Irish super Irish Catholic mother-in-law
born and raised in Dublin she did a
wishing well in Dublin and then now I'm
just perfect wow I don't have true but
you know I like I I leave a space in my
head for spookiness oh me too I think
that's one thing that used to really uh
that's one thing used to help my
imagination so much when I was young is
that anything could be possible you know
you heard a lot more lore and stuff back
then you know that's one thing I really
miss like now it's like everything is um
like I asked my little niece I said you
should use your imagination and she goes
um what is it imagination she thought it
was an app on your phone and I'm like oh
my God like well not to dovetail again
to this goofy uh uh This brilliant
scripted podcast but that is bringing
that back for mom and dads driving
around with their kid they're just gonna
hear a story so let's go into the music
you guys started it during the pandemic
right yeah Dex and Julian came to me
with the idea of my son Tom they all
grew up with Twilight Zone because I had
the mix I had the DVD at my house in the
90s so they're obsessed by it so we want
they want to make a show like it and we
just came today we needed to have rod
and we knew it would be a big budget
thing so we decided to do it scripted
podcast and based on the Twilight Zone
but a comedy version and they went
downtown we went crazy so a scripted
podcast yeah comedy podcast right so
it's basically where you yeah where you
it's where like you guys write it out in
advance right well we wait here's here's
what Adam
to do it we wrote it recorded it and it
sounded like some people were on a
pirate ship we're like wow this is
awesome then we play it for people and
they're just checking their phone that's
pretty good dude whatever we got holy
[ __ ] this is not like old time radio
you're competing for someone's mind
where they got their phone in their hand
so then we kept redoing it restacking it
record it write it add effects better
re-record it more music more effects we
had access to all this Lush music in the
Warner Brothers library because we did
it with Team Coco and they had a deal
with Warner Bros big orchestral score so
you want to make it filmic and uh ear
candy and intensity and then we go but
people get lost they're listening to it
in traffic someone cuts them off [ __ ]
you and then they lose the thread of the
story so we go Clarity is king So we had
to put more Exposition in a funny way so
the narrator Rod so we loaded Clarity we
loaded ear candy effects we made it
potent potent potent to the point where
then we loved it but it took like a year
in a room and these guys Dex and Julian
just became this two-man band because
it's pandemic time so they literally
they they looked at it with a thousand
songs I don't know we got Dex Dex is
here he's sitting in the a thousand
songs or how many songs yeah let's ask
him and this is your son this is your
human son this is my human son yes Dex
Carvey and Julian madelage this is the
two-man team that went crazy in a good
way producing writing and directing it
was such a blast it was such a good
learning experience because you could uh
listen back to something if it didn't
work you can just do it uh right over
immediately did it feel weird like using
like because your father obviously is a
talented instrument that a lot of the
world has used to have humor and to feel
Joy and and to feel different things yes
did it ever feel weird as his son like
is there like a strangeness there like
request you know trying to like does
that ever feel uncomfortable I'd never a
relationship with my father so I don't
you know it's tough for me to gauge any
of that but I'm just curious about it oh
I do it can be super uncomfortable just
because generally shows where it's a
famous dad and his kids uh really suck
it generally sucks that's just common
knowledge here come the kids right yeah
yeah here comes Ronnie Tarantino let's
see what he's got going maybe you could
stand up without him I don't know he's
better there you go yeah and if we can't
see you too yeah
that's Julian widget it's your partner
there yeah that childhood friend uh
lived right next door he would come over
and watch the Twilight Zone Julian and
they're the ones who really went
downtown on this and went a little crazy
we just went crazy with it to be honest
you because we could and we just it
wasn't like a movie you make it you know
it sucks you have to walk away we just
kept redoing it and then we learned the
space now we think we reinvented it and
whoops number four on you know yeah he's
doing very well you guys remember four
on Apple podcast today anyway for
scripted comedy podcast which is a very
tough space so we we we're very proud of
it and we love it and it deals in
Emotion personality too in a subtle way
it has story arcs it has a filmic sense
to it and mostly the word packages and
The rhythms of the characters because
that's what I Harbor in those were so
much fun to do and Dexter your father
play all the characters you play some of
the characters did Julian play some of
them who played what we got we got a few
little ones
um my dad did most of the the voices
just because again it was like I don't
want to have uh you know it's Dana's kid
tries voices for the first time yeah
it's just like we really like this show
so I just wanted to focus on the show
and not about the people involved as
much
but uh did you enjoy so a lot of
producing and writing from your side
yeah I think all I mean that was cool I
mean it was I'm not really that familiar
with
this project but like it's a sketch we
just sat on the mic yeah just stay on
the mic you're good just stay on the mic
we don't yeah but basically we're
riffing and we're we're at a impasse
with the story okay okay and Dex or
Julian would say something like okay the
alien has to stay on Earth what if he
gets addicted to Earth food and he gains
so much weight he can't get home on a
spaceship so I'm like oh [ __ ] that's it
that's it so they're writing in that
kind of way and then we're all rewriting
for clarity and we all learn together I
know a lot more about making uh film or
telling stories now by doing this but
they then they would they would do a
rough edit they would add effects they
would do music we'd work on it again
together and then everyone was wearing
every hat because I would look up from
the mic after doing a take at Dex and
Julian and I would go by them and they
might go I think that last take or this
take and we're picking takes and uh I
just give them a lot of props because
that's I I love crazy and I'm crazy I
mean I don't I I if I'm working on
something like I'll draw a little bit or
play a song I'm as excited about that as
being on Saturday Night Live it's a
weird Discovery it's almost scary that's
all I care about so this was all from
the heart
um and not for money or fame it's just
completely a message in a bottle that
you hope people can get a little piece
in their in their brains for a while and
the weird place it's called it's called
the weird place anywhere where you can
get a podcast yeah we'll put the link
below so people can uh get a hold of it
and check it out now is each episode
different decks or what's that like is
it each episode like Anthology yeah so
Anthology means what just it's basic
three basic stories uh the first one is
about a nuclear submarine 1966 that goes
through a time portal okay and surfaces
in 1738 and sees a pirate ship they
don't even know they've gone back in
time wow and there's a whole story
around that the second one was this
alien who has to come to Earth and
befriend an Earthling to get get them to
help and make bomb making material girls
so he tells this sweet old lady that
that's what he eats on his Planet
ammonium nitrate nitroglycerin could I
have some ammonium nitrates out what do
y'all want the four to eat to eat
because it's food so that one's a little
funnier but he's the one who gets so
heavy he can't escape the spaceship they
become friends and then the final one is
about a guy who's gets bullied by these
guys and he goes to this this
knick-knack store in this strange
colorful character gives him a globe and
it's a magic globe and if you touch the
globe you affect the real world so he
touches the alpha Eiffel Tower it
touches Paris and one day I will go to
Paris and then there's Mayhem in Paris
so that one is really very Twilight Zone
and really special there's a lot of
songs and uh there's a companion piece
called talking weird it's sort of an
after show that Rod interviews some of
the voice actors and there's some
singing in that and Rod is your
character so people know
Rod is we needed a Rod Serling character
and so we needed that gravitas and that
voice to give us that Vibe and the
music's all from the 60s there's no sex
or violence no real violence
um and there it's it's very 60s it has
an earnestness to it you know a
sincerity to it it's not cynical it's
not dark and Rod Sterling so people know
who that is that is a show in the
1960s called The Twilight Zone okay and
there's been reboots Black Mirror was
sort of a brilliant dark version of it
and there was Jordan Peele did did the
Twilight Zone and so we just did our own
thing and we kept it Earnest and we kept
it raw to sized
for our purposes so you know we did a
lot of characters yeah there he is
that's him yeah that's him Justin throw
Jr look at him yeah and is he related to
the um the Archbishop or whatever the
Canadian um you know that's who he looks
like Justin Thoreau well that well I
just keep thinking Justin Thoreau for
Hollywood out there should play Rod
Serling in a biopic yeah because I think
he does look kind of like him if he
could throw up Justin throw if you want
but yeah let's get a quick picture of
Justin Thoreau real quick and then I got
just one more question for Dex too
um
and he loves older women I think he's
into well I was with Jennifer Aniston
for a while right oh no I'm thinking of
the Prime Minister of uh Canada yeah
right Justin Trudeau Trudeau yeah yeah
so you thought he looks like Rod
Sterling yeah oh okay that's funny they
maybe they both do oh that's funny there
you go okay yeah you could carry it off
but you could see that uh Justin Thoreau
who's a brilliant Justin tried her yeah
and Justin Trudeau is the prime minister
of Canada he looks like he's still like
he eats adult applesauce
he does he looks like an applesauce face
yeah if his face was a fruit product it
wouldn't just be an apple it'd be
applesauce it'd be very the runny kind
not the good kind that's bad the shitty
kind like Hi-C you have to look at him
you got have to get Kool-Aid when you
can't afford high C oh there he is Jesus
God Christ thanks got his hands around
the bun there all right that's a good
look for the leader of a large Nation I
can't do the double knuckle grip on some
chick's ass that's what we need in our
Prime Ministers okay I can really my IQ
goes up when I become Dennis yeah you
know I just know though he won't ever
say anything directly as his own poetry
I can't see them on there rocking the
mullet that's a good look Circa 20 20.
yeah spent some money on the studio here
what is this six by eight looks like a
prison cell or something okay dressing
up with the Psychedelic picture good you
put down the Hash Pipe on okay do a
podcast so you know it's just he's uh
just a brilliant kind of awesome I went
on his show one time did you yeah he's
an amazing improviser yeah yeah was it
fun um all right one more question for
Dex let me get it so I don't forget
um yeah is this is this something that
you guys think you would do more of or
what did did this feel like too kind of
harrowing
um
I would love to do it again it was
pretty intense
just because it was just three of us and
we also really it took like half the
time just to figure it out we just
didn't really know how to yeah it's a
lot I'm sure it sounds like a lot I
think we and Julian can talk for a sec
too I I think that we did figure it out
we have a work process now it might be a
little bit like first time you do a
podcast and now you kind of know you
know I've been learning with Spade still
but we we could go faster we would need
a little more help you know maybe a
secondary mixer we hired one yeah we had
Michael Gordon uh from Conan
um great writer we had he's doing some
assisting for us but we were basically a
three-man band but we could move faster
it's like this is proof of concept right
and we may release uh an episode soon we
had an episode that we held that Tom
thought of it was about uh uh valdemar
Putin goes through a wormhole and ends
up in a guy's uh bedroom in in rural
Mississippi oh yeah yeah Mississippi Joe
yeah
excuse me who are you sir who am I sir
what do you you must be KGB agent well
KGB agent I surely don't know what
you're talking about sir
I would you know so that's that's maybe
a bonus episode coming out based on
popular man demand okay yep that's cool
man yeah I think I would love to see
Russia versus Mississippi so I would
love to watch that I'd watch that on
pay-per-view even damn it yeah well I'll
tell you you know the the idea not the
romance or maybe the romance not the
reality but the idea when I gone to
Mississippi and the South
with a gentleman a friend of mine and uh
there is a charm factor a politeness a
way of speaking that to us Northerners
is just very very Charming you know and
uh people say doll and people will damn
I mean they'll breastfeed a damn adult
if they need it you know it's just that
kind of place you know it's not you
darling you know y'all you all need some
breast milk I know you're 47. come on
over here here's my titty now put your
mouth around I'll squeeze real hard
there you go there's your breast milk I
just want to make you feel better I know
I've just committed three felonies but
that breast milk's coming nice and clean
you too I'll give you the other side
yeah it's a very polite Roadhouse and
it's always at a restaurant too you know
yeah it's just the idea of the South and
the movies and you know in the
um what y'all fixing to do or or you
know it's like Al Gore people should
think I did them gay but I wasn't I was
doing a Tennessee gentleman he's just I
take umbrage with your attitude kind of
Madam and he sort of you know put
together as a Tennessee gentleman not a
rural rat scat like you from Deep rural
Louisiana I'm from Nashville Tennessee
and I'll say to you sir that the South
will rise again I tell you you know so I
do love I love Southern Accents I love
Bill Clinton I love being this guy
that's the most seductive no wonder he
got in trouble because this is this
hypnotizes women this gets them all
bunched up downstairs if you know what I
mean when I say baby I said you you have
the prettiest eyes I've ever seen and
they will drop drawers in a second I
mean I'll fold my nuts into a dang
vagina right now brother I'll meet you
halfway but my favorite old-fashioned
dick joke is this woman says to me she
wants 12 inches I said hey baby I don't
fold it in half for anybody I mean
that's the best dip joke you've never
heard that
that's the best dick joke ever who has
this guy Larry Reeb has this joke he
said huh
he goes uh my wife told me never answer
the phone during sex I said what if it's
you calling
it's just an old joke but I love it oh I
loved old old-fashioned my favorite joke
ever it's like what's the last thing you
want to hear when you're getting a
[ __ ] when when you're giving a
[ __ ] to Willie Nelson
I'm not Willie Nelson
how do you get a dog to stop pumping
your leg
pick them up and blow them
I love these old jokes what's the worst
thing you can hear when you get a
prostate exam look ma no hands these are
just classics I used to do this whole
bit about can you have a prostate exam
joke in your act let me think I don't do
this one anymore but if you need it you
can have it all right I might take it
this is like I hate you know you have to
bend over and they're gonna probe you
and it's like I like to take the power
back so they start to do the exam and I
always go is that all you
come on
get in there get in there you do a lot
with genitals you know being crooked or
only the balls or they're folded or
creased it's a funny Rhythm you have
I've I'd fold my nuts in half and put
them in a
that's your [ __ ] first origami dude
is your damn nuts you know because
they're so malleable and so like it's
really such a CR if somebody gave you a
pair of nuts it would blow your mind you
know like in just loose off of a body
um yeah how it's built and everything
it's really insane
um yeah and there's two nuts in there
you know that's the craziest thing about
you sometimes I forget that I have two
nuts inside of my nuts all the time I
just forget about it I mean two
testicles inside the Ville scrotum using
the test and the penile will enlarge yes
do you remember sex ed you were going to
sex ed the first oh God how embarrassing
you know dude we all War I remember all
the guys with like one guy wore like a
[ __ ] suit or like a little tux you
know like dude what is going this guy is
spaced bro people would wear cologne
people be [ __ ] drinking cologne guys
putting cologne on in their car before
like it was the first cologne to go to
sex education like they're seducing sex
education or was the teacher a hot no it
was a man dude but just sex education
they wanted to smell good for sex
education we just thought it was time
for sex so we were just everybody but we
would we would we would wear Hooter
clamps just to keep our junk in place
really Hooter clamps they're just sort
of like this thing you wear like a
leather diaper that keeps your junk in
one place no I made that up but that's a
joke we used to have Hooter plants are
you wearing a Hooter clamp tonight yeah
I got my Hooter clamp on good I mean we
left for hours about Hoover clamps it
would just keep your kind of wiener down
which was an invented idea maybe Brad
thought of that I don't know just when
that time when you're 20 22 and you just
go off on those like we said just just
laughing now did you ever feel left out
if your brother started to get erections
and stuff and you didn't have any of
that or anything like that
mostly erections were private did you
ever do a circle jerk with your brother
and sisters I mean no we never did
anything like that I never wanted to ask
one time we got under this blanket and
things were like a little strange but it
wasn't anything too crazy and our butt
and my buddy was there too it was just
almost like a Native American type of
deal you know it wasn't Native American
like you were under the blankets like a
tenth yeah and then things to our
attempt started to form in your pants
and you didn't know what it meant and
you ran away we were all just kind of
chatting naked under this blanket and
then everybody started getting an
erection I think nobody wanted to like
admit it you know so everybody was just
kind of pretending like they weren't
getting in a wreck we were more innocent
we would make my sister play waitress
like on a rainy day and go she wanted to
play with us now you can't you go but
you could play waitress okay she'd make
us root beer floats and stuff and she'd
bring them in like a waitress to go yeah
okay clean it up you know next day can
we get a cheeseburger with Jesus she
became a really good fry cook for a
while because she wanted to be our
friend so bad we just put her to work I
mean this was the this is a rough and
tumble carvies it's like the sons of
getting older I mean we were we were
just badass weirdos building forts tents
fighting was it weird so whenever you
started to have like a lot of popularity
in your life from work and stuff was it
oh was that was it tough with your
relationship with your brothers like did
you ever get scared like oh this is
gonna take away because I felt that in
my own life and I felt it but I'm just I
guess I've worried about it so that's a
real thing that's gonna take away or
it's gonna make my brother think I don't
care about him as much or something I
don't know well I just nothing changed
on my side but my brother Scott had a
sense of humor about it he would
introduce himself after I got some
amount of famous Dana carvey's brother
hi what are you my name is Dana carvey's
brother my other name is Scott Curry but
my primary name is Dan carvery's brother
so we just laughed about it and just
kept in touch I would do these things
called Lost weekends to stay in touch
with my friends my high school friends
my brother when I was you know Peak SNL
so we'd all go to Vegas everyone gets
their own room we go see shows we went
out to Lake Mead when it was there ever
when we get a wave runner we'd have beer
and sandwiches in the front and we'd go
out there with crystal clear and we go
to islands and dive off rocks and just
have a blast so I just went the other
way I made a lot of new friends you know
from in show business but I have a lot
of core core friends and you know Fame
is a [ __ ] you know I mean
there's no way around it it's just very
strange and you're you're still on the
upslope so
um your brother did you look up to him
he was older yeah not as kids I didn't
but as adults I really have you know
these really really special guy and so
yeah I don't worry I just I don't know
it was just sometimes I just don't want
him to think that I I don't know I think
we do a pretty decent job it's it's just
weird and then the money comes I
remember just I had the thing like I'd
go to a mall and I think everywhere I
look I could buy it anywhere I look I
could buy it you know and I I one time
went in and I got like a Mercedes
because like an Elvis move at a mall no
not at a mall a dealership because I got
I got I left the mall and I pointed at
this one and it was like a Mercedes
Coupe but I realized later on it had a
plastic windshield it was like 125 000
it'd be like 250 now so I turned it back
in and I got a big giant Mercedes giant
SLE 550 huge thing and I was going into
7-Eleven just in the valley and people
were looking at me so then I just went
to a Honda Pilot ever since then I like
to get rid of stuff I don't want I have
one car one wife you know you know it's
like I don't need a lot of things I like
guitars I like things I can interact
with you know a woman a guitar a piano a
swimming pool you know things that are
stuff that works well I can't get that
excited about a chair and just look at
the chair that's all right my wife does
you know it's just an interior designer
mine an aesthetic mind I'm more in the
internal world but it's not
self-congratulatory but going back full
circle to your brother yeah it's so it's
um you could feel maybe a little guilt
about it because you're changing the
dynamic of how he's perceived you know
which is normal
it's not yeah I think it's you I don't
want him to ever I don't know I just
didn't want my brother to think that he
felt that I ever felt like I was more
important than him or something like
that I don't know and maybe that's all
egotistical to even think that way you
know it's you're just a passenger in
this so you just did this I don't even
know what your resume was before you did
this and then you got really successful
extraordinary successful and that's just
the train you're writing you couldn't
will it but you were active you did this
necessary steps but this Lane that
you're in now where it's Theo Von world
and you run a you're a CEO of a business
and you don't bow down to anyone no one
tells you you're fired this is awesome
I'm glad I live long enough to see this
that's us doing this this scripted
podcast with just a laptop in the
effects and all the things we could get
for ourselves it's such an equal playing
field for art and creativity and you're
like one of the big you know people out
there that have done this you and Tim
Dillon and others but it's a magic world
and you can't hope that you're
successful I'll be therapists for a
second yeah that's not nothing you just
ride in the train that you know and what
happens over time I'll tell you this
much
everyone's all excited you're famous and
then it gets boring yeah it might be 10
more years but some point it's full
circle back to Theo just like and you're
still going and doing stuff but like
been there done that they're used to all
the stuff but in early heady days of it
you're picking up checks you're renting
cars you know and uh it's just a little
bit of a whoop-dee-doo I mean I I sort
of got famous in a sense at 31 or 32.
and
um so I had a long Runway before that
you know if you make it as a child actor
that's that's [ __ ] up you know yeah
it's scary man it just killed that one
kid you know you saw that Aaron Carter
he just yeah you know he drowned out he
drowned out I think he they said he was
huff and Duster
which I've done I'm not gonna lie about
that what is that specifically huff and
duster yeah asdfl Sim or whatever you
know or ever whatever it is oh okay and
you hit you know hit the duster but yeah
I've hit it before I love it but I think
it's sad to see what you know he was a
child star and then next you know he's
got six or seven service animals I mean
he had a damn you know he was in the
damn Iditarod it looked like the guy had
so many service hands yeah and he was
getting tattoos and neck tattoos and
just once it creeps up on the face you
just feel like it's a cry for help you
know it's like what can I put on my face
it'll make me okay and the interesting
part about therapy is just checking your
thoughts and that's a daily thing you
know cognitive behavioral therapy
because if you get redundantly into
those negative thoughts and you water
those roots and then they get in your
head I'm a loser I'm a loser I'm a loser
that's you have to really fight all that
stuff you know it's really interesting
game inside your head it all happens in
here all your joy your sadness your pain
just it's all here you know and how you
decide it is that's how it is you ever
meet a really I have a friend Chuck
who's just a really happy person oh yeah
these guys talks like this you know he's
like the other day you know I was
running on my hop off my bike you know
and the wind was coming I don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on you know he's
a mechanic for United he's a really
bright guy but he's just got this Dems
and does thing of like you know you ever
go to New York and these Brooklyn guys I
had a friend who passed away he was like
you know he's really like you know the
guy you know God Rest his soul my mother
did this for me and this and that you
know you got to take care of your family
it's a way of just simplifying this ride
this 70 80 90 year ride that we're all
taking on just keep it real basic right
here I'm with you right now we're
bonding over humor and telling stories
you know and I think that you know the
Theo's you know he's a good guy you know
and you had a nice chat he would come to
SNL and he was basketball freak he would
critique my SNL with basketball stats
he'd come up because I do churchly
whatever he goes 28 points 12 boards six
assists
you know his catchphrase was this which
is another good one he did with my
brother Scott you do what you do I do
what I do rub a chicken capisce I don't
know why it's rubber chicken but it just
works you do what you do I do what I do
rub a chicken capiche and then this
oh yeah yeah well he made everything
simple same with Chuck living the moment
and it's a struggle if you're you know a
curious active brain but it's uh you
know it's fun yeah staying in that yeah
I think it's true it's that it does all
happen between the walls of your own
head you know it's crazy that that's
really where you get that's really where
you gotta tend the soil a lot and not
even over 10 it sometimes you get so
stuck on taking care of yourself but
then that's all you're doing you know
it's like being mentally or physically
or all of it mentally all of it but all
of it it's like I gotta make sure I'm
okay you know something that's a a
hamster wheel people can really get on
nowadays
um yeah I think nothing has to happen is
something that's helped me recently you
get all pent up nothing has to happen
yeah you know this could have got
canceled nothing has happened just just
everyone calm down we're just here yeah
nothing has to happen we're not going to
the movie no no not not tonight yeah
nothing has to happen it's just the way
everybody calm down and just laugh your
ass off and make art no nuggets no
nuggets no nuggets tonight damn it
nothing has to happen dude nothing has
to happen
um it's okay no one's thinking about me
right now
if anyone out there is thinking is Theo
okay I mean everyone's inside their own
kiosk you know
yeah I think um
it was interesting so you so when you
got you had a lot of Fame that happened
and then you kind of took a break did
you is this okay this is a from this
outside of perspective oh no no totally
I I had this weird took a break was it
to be a dad no it's very much more
complicated than that so basically I did
all this stuff before SNL because I was
insecure but I was in the club starting
to kick ass but I did a sitcom with
Mickey Rooney Nathan Lane in New York
Mickey Rooney Mickey Rooney you read his
book no I know Mickey though oh he
passed away didn't he he did but he made
it to like 95. yeah dude did you hear
about the story where something he slept
at somebody's house for like a couple
weeks right yeah oh no he let somebody
stay in his house for a couple weeks he
was married to some like bombshell right
yeah he he at all six of the hottest
stars in the world and I said Mickey
how'd you get him he goes money makes
you handsomer money makes you handsomer
is his own word but go ahead what was
his story a guy stated his place for a
couple of weeks and he left him a couple
paintings as a gift and they were uh and
then like a few months later he was
getting a divorce or something and so
he's a friend help him move and he said
oh you can have those somebody left him
here and they were Salvador dollies they
were two Salvador Dali paintings wow and
he talked about struggling with his with
money most of his life oh yeah and uh
and then here he was giving away a
couple dollies like that she's kind of
crazy yeah there he is right there there
is when I oh there I am it's the tallest
I've ever been Mickey's like he called
himself I'm a fire plug you know built
like a fire and Nathan Lane and that he
was my grandfather and I was just cast
uh from NBC I got a deal frequently I
had a teen idle thing going on and go
you're gonna play Mickey Rooney's
grandson in New York and then I met
Nathan and Mickey thought I was gay the
whole time wow he would put his arm
around Nathan and look at me and go I'm
just glad we like girls
and he finally got money because he was
broke for 50 years anyway he was Rooney
was broke I called up Warner Brothers in
1955. I said this is Mickey Rooney he
was always doing this I need a job and
he'd stare off and he'd go he hung up on
me
and then you'd come into the the studio
and you'd hear him down the hall
how long is Rod from Robert Redford been
in the business he's one of those guys
who talked until he ran out of air how
long has Robert Redford been in the
business 10 years I've been in the
business 62 years how old are you 62 in
two months I mean he's one of those guys
as a baby oh yeah he had so many he
would said this a thousand times
literally literally he would say this
every day I was the which he was he was
the number star number one star in the
world 1937. I was the number one star in
the world you hear me bang
the world and he did that you hear me
bang the world
I saw it
but he had finally had money he was
doing a Broadway show on our show he
went to the racetrack all week it was
old show business we had a guy who was
five feet tall his head was and we would
just rehearse with him all week but
Mickey would have like five thousand
dollars and he'd put it in front of my
face and goes think I can afford lunch
and he had a 38. he didn't like the
script he would bring it out
and he throw the script this script is
Kaka and he's wavering this 38 around
and he puts it back in he goes they're
not gonna get me who the hell he was
going to kill Juan Corona this serial
killer before this I was gonna go to see
Juan Corona and I would say you know I
am I'm Mickey Rooney I was gonna plug
him full of holes
he was the craziest greatest he would
play a piano because he was a jack of
all trades his piano chords he goes this
is Stephen sondheim's favorite song but
then we bonded he thought I was a hack
and an idiot but then
I was able to do Jimmy Stewart for him
so that's when I when I got him I know
how you doing Mick yeah good good to say
uh and said he was an impressionist too
he's like Sammy Davis Jr just could do
anything so we got going toward the end
and Nathan and I and you know there's so
much more to it but Meg Ryan played my
girlfriend set Scatman Crothers first
time I really befriended this beautiful
older black man from the south I think
or whatever but Scatman Carruthers and
he was like such a poet my brother came
out to visit me and he say see that man
over there with the broom he's an artist
we're all about us and he played the
ukulele and he'd walk around the studio
it had an unmarked bottle this big of
pills and he just chugged some other
vitamins I'm going to 100 I'm doing
Mickey now I'm going to a hundred so
what happened was he had he he smoked a
lot of weed it was always weed
everywhere Scatman yeah so during the
break I went back to San Francisco there
he is he was the nicest guy so Scott and
I got like 10 we got like two lids of
Colombian pot those days you'd fly with
it I guess we put in a suitcase we gave
it to Scatman and Rockefeller Center
this is 1981 Mickey Rooney's around his
cat here you go next day he's in the
elevator with me he says because you
know he grew up during secrecy with pot
he said the music was good uh might I
get a pound so it was the best body ever
had and he could look at not even look
at you and roll a joint and it was
closed on both ends oh so then after the
show got canceled he was living in Van
Nuys and so Scott and I brought a bag of
Santa Cruz Colombian we didn't even
smoke pot at that point maybe a teeny
bit but we brought it to him he played
ukulele he goes I got a bad wheel and it
was just so such a sweet
such a sweet guy that was a cool part of
that story of meeting him and hanging
out with Scatman oh yeah there's nothing
better that feels I feels better than
giving like good weed to a black guy I
feel like too there's just something as
a white guy that about there that feels
good you know I guess so I just you know
I didn't I grew up you know mostly as a
white neighborhood and we had an
integrated high school when I was 14 I
was standing there Carmon High School
2500 kids and they brought all the kids
in from East Palo Alto so these buses
showed up and 500 black kids came in
to the school and all I was worried
about was they'd think I was prejudiced
so I'd say something that sounded
Prejudice but then you know we all they
all ran on the team we all hung out but
Scatman was just sort of he's just a
poet you know just everything he said
was poetry you know some of these people
like yeah my dad had this fellow named
uh his last name Wilson right and he had
a one of his limbs was shortened out
right he probably had that you know he
had that damn Sand Wedge on him he had
that pitching wedge on his left and so
they would they would cut a bunch of he
had a bunch of pieces of Tire cut and
just kind of glue either yeah or nailed
onto the bottom of that interesting and
he would stand sometimes when he didn't
have his uh good shoe or whatever he
would stand on a little stoop so he
looked even from far off right it was
just a big he didn't want to be uneven
you know was he a vet or was it just
congenital or an accident he just
probably I don't know maybe he got
raised in an area on an uneven surface I
have no idea what happened to him right
but they um he used to put uh he would
hang out with my father and he would you
know go get lunch form and stuff
sometime my dad worked in a French
Quarter for a little while selling I
think some kind of [ __ ] but this guy
would help him out and he so he would
put cinnamon on his palm of his hand and
let us lick it off when we were children
you never forget that my grandmother
bring date cookies and stuff and that
seemed exciting
um any old person Subway to treat
anything they hook you up let you lick
their hand or whatever yeah it just made
you feel one thing I appreciate like my
mother had a friend that was just from
Montana her name was cookie so she's an
old person who just giggled all the time
when you didn't meet a bitter you just I
met a lot of bitter people they didn't
like being old and my date you know it's
like okay
show business especially or life is a
bitterness Factory so be one of those
cheerful don't be mad at someone for
being young because James fiorentino was
mad at me for being young when I did
Blue Thunder really so I was in this
mock helicopter another show that I did
he was purely doing massive amounts of
coke he had a styrofoam cup this big a
straight vodka when we were in the mock
helicopter with our helmets on acting
and then I got fired from that that's
crazy people would do that thing because
they don't do that now I know it was so
obvious because he got out of the
chopper his dealer was over there
and then I thought I'll just take a sip
of water I was so young and naive he
would take he was like Scarface he'd
take the script out and he just pounded
on the instrument panel and the Frank
helicopter we're like 10 feet in the air
and they're blowing steam at us you know
okay and we're pretending like there we
are I love this guy had a great haircut
dude you do I could definitely see if a
gay dude rolled up bro
you are toast oh yeah yeah I was jaffo
just another frust look at that I'll
throw a punch look like the same guy
well that was a while back but yeah no
that's me being the macho guy but I just
had lines in the back of the chapter
he'd say jaffo incoming Jam him and I
would say I am jamming I am jamming sir
you know I wanted to be I wanted to be
Richard Pryor or something or Steve
Martin I'm in this one I bet they play
that at so many bath houses on Loop dude
I am jamming I am jamming I am
I bet you were on so many you were not
getting paid I'm not jamming but someone
else is I think you need to sell us but
if you stole tickets in specific areas
man you would really really but he would
call me at night what are they saying
about me well then you're doing drugs
and you're out of your mind okay just
checking see you later but I got fired
they put me in the helicopter with that
suit on and then they uh they fired me
they said come on down the whole crew
was there and I had to come down to
ladder wearing that and I didn't think
oh you're fired I am now they could have
told me before I got in the monkey suit
so I gotta do it's like an old show
called Brandon I'm walking across
everybody you know kind of waving
humiliated I go to the Wardrobe guy who
I kind of befriended I'm kind of shook
up and I go man I'm funny I can do stuff
and he put his hand on my shoulder like
sure kid it's okay kid you know and then
I ran into him after SNL he goes God you
just get more right I didn't [ __ ] you
know so I got revenge but that was
another crazy I had some crazy people
you know experiences but did you ever
trial from MacGyver that makes me think
about that looking at that show and then
seeing you it seemed like they almost
would have put you on there I don't know
at some point I stopped because what
they did was they were
giving me 7 500 a week and I'm from
middle class family that's a lot of
money yeah so I was like doing all this
stuff was a waste of time but in the
meantime I was doing stand up so finally
I got they offered me funster Hall it
was like a Punky Brewster spin-off so
the pilot was going to be 30
000 in 1984. that's a lot of money so I
just thought nah can't do this anymore
so then all I did was clubs oh because
you were making too much money touring
well I was just in comedy clubs I was
mostly Seattle Bay Area had like five
full-time clubs so I started going you
know I started headlining I was
headlining but even bigger rooms and I
was I was making plenty of money yeah
you know 2 000 a week and so I just did
that for two years and then I did one
final thing that was different was uh a
movie called tough guys with Bert
Lancaster and Kirk Douglas so they
became my buddies that was weird I was
the third wheel in that movie Kirk
Douglas is uh you just passed he passed
made to 102. he was the Dad huh oh yeah
yeah and Kirk Douglas like he talked
like this and it's a ton of great movies
uh and Bert Lancaster these were like
this is like working with Tom Cruise and
Brad Pitt or something you know and so
Michael Landon did you ever work with no
I would love there we go again yeah look
look I was the pro I was the straight
man again what are you guys doing I'm
telling we're gonna rob a bank yeah they
were uh I'm Kirk Douglas when he saw me
I go I play him Richie Kirk Douglas said
well you're perfect you look exactly
like Richie and then Bert Lancaster said
how many movies have you done I go well
this is my first you've done one I've
done 72.
so that's the way they talk you can look
it up
so look at all this [ __ ] I did it's a
different time but I'm on SNL as the
church lady eight months later I mean I
just came out of nowhere what yeah but
they were it was a thrill being around
them and listening and tell the stories
Jack Nicklaus had won the Masters golf
at age 46 and people thought and they're
like I had pimples at 46. 46. he's an
old it's not even not even Middle East
and they talk like that and eventually I
started doing this thing which I was
Politically Incorrect you can cut it out
but just for my own amusement
late night writer's room stuff I did
them as lovers you know Kirk and Bert
and I don't really like blue humor but I
thought their voices would blend so
funny yeah that the comedy was about the
Rhythm and the vernacular
I want you and I want you now I need to
have you okay don't rush me two men
having fun doesn't mean we're gay come
on do what you gotta do don't keep
[ __ ] around like that son I only got
so much play down there you keep [ __ ]
around like that I gotta pull out and
splooge all over your backside so that
was the poem that made Lovitz throw up
in a parking garage so I would do 20
minute versions of this for the writer
Zone could do Burton Kirk and I did it
on an HBO special but I do it with
lovetts and love it because I would just
go so far with it you know
I don't know why I need you but I want
all of it tonight you won't so what I
did was then I made it into they're just
gonna wrestle and I made some tapes from
friends and sent it to Bill Hader I'd
like you to come over to my house three
five nine Cannon Drive this is 1952.
I'll be there with bell song There's a
gate off the side the code is seven five
four pound we're gonna wrestle we're
gonna wrestle naked style I'm looking
forward to it would you like me to bring
anything lemonade bring me some lemonade
we'll lather up and then we'll wrestle
first man out of the ring I look forward
to it just naked I might be wearing
diaper 455 Cannon Drive I'll be there at
4 P.M make it 4 15. I gotta get ready
for the real so it's just me having a
party with those rhythms because when I
do this stuff I'm the audience in my
head two I'm trying to make myself so
that's uh I've been canceled three times
that's great for to be the audience in
your own head aren't you a little bit
sometimes if you're on a roll like if
you're doing bits and it's packed and
you're rolling and you're doing it a
little bit better or a little bit
different than you ever have so you're
turning yourself on going back to yeah
at the beginning of the podcast and what
did that do turns on the audience you
know if you get to turn yourself on but
um that's all I'm trying to do all the
time I did Biden last night on come on I
was just trying to get get that that
feeling of a rhythm that makes it makes
makes me laugh you know yeah and he
going come on let's get real
okay I'm not kidding around here you
know it was like the you know we're all
well endowed by our creator and all men
to believe that all men are secreted
equally with liberty and John John suits
for all man-made kind and ridiculous no
joke of race
Clear Water her color balloons I walked
on the moon you know he yells walked on
the moon Lance Armstrong he says Buzz
Buzz Buzz Lightyear it was cold and dark
we got home the grace of God president
Harris was there I'm Joe Biden so I was
just kind of trying to find a character
and a rhythm because Trump is so easy
I'm gonna make an announcement soon
you're gonna love it I'm gonna say
things like you wouldn't believe and I
know how to say things people don't want
me to say what I'm going to say it
pretty soon and we're gonna do and
you're gonna be happy like you wouldn't
believe so they're just fun fun rhythms
you know I did one as Obama as a
preschool teacher Jack and Jill went up
the hill
Jill decided she wanted to become a jack
and jack decided he wanted to become a
Jill it's a teachable moment so anyway
that's all these are just rhythms I'm
still working on I did them on Campbell
but I like to do them on theophone is it
thank you it's a nice game yeah you have
a good sense of humor so sometimes man I
want to learn how to do one with you
real quick what is like one that you
think I could do
um summer just sounds well I would say
the quickest one and these are just
these are ad hoc they're just
traditional is walking you can just
start with that voice the one I
distilled was Christopher Walken sees an
amazing magic trick so it's really quick
Christopher Walken sees an amazing magic
trick
wow
whoa whoa whoa you're making three
syllables out of one word instead of wow
wow whoa and then down now down now
there you go oh no why whoa don't know
why well it's a great character you
should play a hit man that talks like
that Gotta Kill Ya don't know why plug
you full of holes
no but he's like everyone does him
trying to think like a oh dude you
should do Morgan Freeman oh yeah they
said it would take a man 600 years
hold on let me try it again
they said it would take a man 600 years
to get out of this here prison
but Andy Dufresne did it in less than
20. that is good that is very good
pretty good yeah
yeah it's interesting too
um there is fun to throw your voice is
it weird because some of you your
friends have died and you still do their
voice well I have Dino stepanopoulos is
a great writer
uh he every time one of my Impressions
dies he texts me so when George Bush
died he texted me or Regis filming you
know but there's a passage of time you
don't do it the day of but David and I
do Norm because we miss norm and we want
to do norm and we know that Norm would
have a twinkle in his eye and would be
smiling if he heard us trying to do them
you know hey they they say uh Penny
saved is like what do you call Penny
earned right yeah that's like a thousand
that's 100 return that's like now you
can't get that right you know Jack me
Nimble jabby quick you know Gemini candy
said okay what is he bipolar what are
you doing over there you know he was
just that brilliant mind yeah David
he'll do that when we're like David
where Norm just describes like he's like
yeah I'm trying to like uh hold on I'm
more about this
so I'm trying to like uh I don't know
what are you talking about it's like a
it's like I walk through this thing it's
like a what it's like a tall rectangle
like a what is this like it's a doorway
but like he would just talk about like
I'm in this room and it's just men and
there's men peeing in there I don't even
I know I've seen this have you guys seen
this thing he did a thing and I don't
know if John has talked about this John
Lovitz but so it's like yeah he had a
gambling issue right hey John give me
give me give me come on you did his act
John's going on give me eight hundred
dollars I got a camel come on you know
so John's like okay so the next day John
goes you know can I have my 800 he goes
no I don't have 800 he goes what you owe
it to me why are you so mad I lost eight
thousand dollars you only I lost 800 why
are you so angry he just turned it on
him and John was like John Norm would
always [ __ ] with him and say I'm a
better Stan no he goes I'm a better
standing than you you know I'm like a
better stand-up than you are because I
haven't done it longer and love it so
get so mad excuse me yeah well you owe
it to me that's the best that he does
that John has his own character he
doesn't even know where it came from
hello
um but yeah as far as the 90s thing
which you asked is so I did two shitty
movies for three million dollars each
they were terrible I shouldn't have done
them I just didn't know what I was doing
I came off with too much heat I had
Wayne's World
Pro Bush uh Carson I was doing all this
stuff came together so too much heat and
I didn't really know what to do as a
middle class kid Canal wasn't 30 times
three million and I hated it so much I
said then I had two other offers pay or
play
Hans and Franza girlyman dilemma but we
wrote it with Arnold he dropped out so I
didn't want to do that Bob odikirk and I
wrote a western called Tucson for me and
John Lovitz that John with that fell out
and so I and that was three million pair
of play but I was okay to get rid of
that they've tried to put us together in
Bad Boys another three million Pair play
but then the script just wasn't right
and I it was a hot oven at that point
for me so I I got out of that so then I
just sort of stopped and then I had two
kids but it wasn't it then they went
along and then I did the variety show I
did a special and then I did the variety
show uh with you know with Louis CK and
you know you guys had great writers on
that great show
well Smigel was it was he you know I I
interviewed Louis C.K you know he was
brilliant then and uh we had we had an a
team for sure when you decided to like
take out so was it a decision to take a
break or was just like this kind of
feels what I should do was it like
specifically to kind of be a parent was
it to make sure that like there was
there was some of that we moved up to
Northern California I was also sort of
disillusioned you know because the movie
thing once you make those two things and
they stick to you then you're just in a
hole to dig out of in a way if I'd done
I had Hans and Franz the girlyman
dilemma and others that I was working on
I just made it's just a misstep I always
think of big life big mistakes it's okay
to have regrets but then at that point I
could make a fortune in stand-up right
so I could work I would take two months
off at Christmas I would take the
Summers off so I could be a present dad
and make a [ __ ] ton of money and
especially corporate dates I didn't want
to do them so they'd say this much I'd
say no I don't want to do it and they go
how about this much I don't want to do
it then they'd say this much I go and a
private jet I actually don't want to do
it okay what kind of private jet uh Gulf
Stream okay so then I started doing
those interstitially yeah so I was able
to take care of everybody financially
but uh I was in no man's land I was
untethered but you know Fame was not
something that I was I'm kind of like
other there's a there's some of us where
Fame didn't quite settle with this like
it's scary some people embrace it and
love it and I don't judge that at all
are very easy with it for me I'm kind of
an introverted extrovert so being famous
was not it was a very odd thing the
money was fun and the creativity is fun
but the fame part you know I don't know
so it's kind of scary but that's how I
navigated that I just throw those
numbers out so people know because my
wife so I was doing stand-up while back
and I would just tease the crowd and go
I know you're thinking like why am I
here it's like 20 seats in in the valley
and I I know me too but I'm a
millionaire and stuff like that so
because you don't want people go oh he
was so big and now he's poor so yeah it
was never a problem and
um now it's just full circle
everything's real in in real time for me
and so this this weird place thing is
just super fun flying the wall with
David it's super fun I mean so I'm just
having complete creative fun with both
those things I'm not frustrated I'm not
in a shitty movie or stupid TV show yeah
you know I'm doing my own thing now
you know what was it like watching your
kids be funny what did you like was it
what was it like watching your son like
was that kind of interesting having had
your own relationship with your own dad
and your brothers and stuff what was it
like when you were a dad and then you
had a couple of boys like what was some
of that kind of like
um well we just had we just had a lot of
fun we had a lot of games you know they
were just game for anything we do things
like um on a rainy day set up an
obstacle course around the house and
time them yeah and they'd run they did
the classic like massive pillow uh
massive well we did the pillow throw it
was called and so they would I get all
the pills from the couch and they would
run across on the carpet and I would try
to get them under their feet and fall
and they love they loved all the games
you know uh Hide and Go Daddy which they
would go in the room and they would hide
I knew where they were but I would creep
around and go I don't really know where
they are this time you hear the closet
door shaking you know so they and they
have their own friends in their own
humor even as little kids they were you
know but we um we just had a lot a lot
of fun a lot they had a child of Freedom
up there and Northern California suburbs
kids could just go out a lot more and
you know sort of so I don't know if Dex
can jump on the mic on this one but yeah
I'm just kind of I guess I'm just kind
of curious you know I guess we just had
a lot of fun we I watched a lot of
movies had a lot of rituals and you know
we went to a vacation a lot to Montana
a lot
and we just were in Montana and a very
nostalgic you know for Dex and Tom to be
up there in Montana right Dex oh it's
the best state unbelievable was Fred
Wolfe up there or not
at that time because he's up there all
the time too yeah if you go to Flathead
Lake in August and you catch a nice day
it's like Tahoe no one's on the lake and
the water is just temperate the
mountains I mean it's a magic Place
Northwestern Montana Missoula where I
was born and where we were this summer I
mean tubing and stuff on just on an
incredible motorboat right Dex it was
the best two and behind a Bose is my is
this one of the best things on the
planet that's whenever you was was it
like whenever was there ever competition
with you and your brother like make your
dad laugh were you guys like kind of
funny was it I'm just trying to think of
like what it's like to have humor like
with your father I never had like
moments with my dad where we made each
other laugh that I can remember anything
I think I was just too young so I guess
I'm just maybe there's no question I
didn't have it with my dad either
um most of the time I think I was a
regular dad you know I wasn't always
doing voices and characters right text
but well when we were doing when you're
working up for your special and we were
you let Tom and I go on the road with
you that that would get a little
competitive you know because uh Tom and
I would be opening for yourself you know
Tom like just crushed yeah like oh man I
got the oh you know the brothers are
doing stand up and uh you know it's yeah
we but I would just say we just had a
lot of fun my wife who likes a very tidy
home just gave them full run of it most
the time you know the airsoft battles
where there's a million pellets and
their cousins would come over and
couches and they'd be in there fighting
for hours
loading up and you know I couldn't watch
them they'd be on skateboards going down
a steep hill so my mind was too active
on that thing but my my wife could watch
them go down the hill and you know they
had a they had a very free childhood in
a lot of ways don't you think that's X
great get you know bike riding I
couldn't ask for more fun they did a lot
of Independence yeah Norton yeah uh
North Bay Mill Valley
yeah little Steven Spielberg Town wow
and Julian Julian mattelich was there
too and now with full circle here they
are working on this thing years later
isn't that funny the weird place which
what we're always in we're all always in
the weird place man
it's such a Twilight Zone life is yeah
it really is it's it's a touch reality
is sort of because I feel like your
dreams
are and your memories are very similar
you know you dream something but if like
you try to like hold it in your brain
you in fourth grade or something it's
it's kind of in that place where you
would hold a dream you know so it's sort
of elusive isn't it did that really
happen
you know in fourth grade when we would
because you're you're remembering just
an images in your head and we skipped
the rocks and I beat my brother that
time you know I hit six six skips you
know skipping rocks was a pretty cool
thing escaping rocks is a it's still a
conquistadorian event if you can get if
you can get into it and do it well yeah
I missed the days when things were a lot
more simpler and things would be like I
remember walking down the street
somebody invited somebody their family
is somebody had died over there and they
buried them in their yard right to do
insurance money because they weren't
going to tell anybody and get that check
wow me and my buddy Summerall are
walking down the street and next thing
you know we get invited to a damn
funeral so we're in the backyard at the
oh wow at these folks house and they're
burying the damn grandfather in there in
the ground and then we'd go back there
and play kickball and [ __ ] back there
and he was in the ground for like
probably 11 months for the cop they
figured it out you know some
you know that's that's extraordinary a
cadaver buried in the yard and we had to
do a I remember what they said does
anybody want to say a great uh say
anything right and my buddy he said
Grace like you say at dinner or
something he didn't know what to do I
guess we were just children wow he said
God is great God is good God we thank
you for this food and I'm like this is a
[ __ ] that was we're standing there by
the end yeah we were Scott and I were in
the good time though pet cemetery team
Under The Willow Tree so the animal
y'all were burying him out there huh she
almost had a little bit of land huh well
no a quarter acre there was a willow
tree whoa and that's a little close to
me burying a dead animal bro well we uh
well where else we gonna do with them
take them to the dump I don't give a
damn if you don't have a half acre bro
no we we it was a short you know boots
got Rigamortis in the in the laundry
room out in the garage so we cannot go
we're touching boots and boots like so
boots has ants ants ants coming in his
mouth and he's he's kind of stiff or not
yeah I'm not sure he's dead so we get
the shovel and we're bringing boots down
to the pet cemetery the willow tree and
we dig the hole and drive we put boots
in we both heard we thought we heard
and we go I go what should we do he goes
he's gone or anyway
so we buried and tiger and then Pepe
Pepe got run over my brother Mark was
sort of not a good driver so he backed
up overhead she took a nap under the
tire we came out before it was a little
cute little poodle the head was all
flattened out but he said he never felt
a bump Scott and I got to shovel this
time it was a not it wasn't a question
mark down there right next to the boot
foreign
you know so we buried a lot of stuff
anyway no but yeah we had a kind of a
Suburban but it was low population a lot
of open land yeah and so a lot of
getting in hollowed out trees and
smoking cigarettes oh yeah Boo Radley
and out there yeah getting in the hollow
tree and getting sometimes getting stuck
in it you know and uh and fights fist
fights and headlocks you know cut it out
cut it out you know a lot of just like
my brother got through a dart and like
stuck it stuck in my leg I had to pull
it out you know but anyway it's real
[ __ ] yeah yeah I know it's just there's
a there's uh we have a symbiotic yeah
borrowed some money off me one time to
buy drugs right and I didn't know he's
buying it for him and his mother or
whatever but I went down there a couple
weeks later to get my money back you
know I'd loaned it to him like two
dollars and fifty cents and I needed it
you know holidays were coming up and
all of that and so I went under their
property and they had like 11 people
lived in like a house this big as this
room and there was people sleeping in
the sink and I was so scared to ask for
the money and then him and his mom
started fighting about drugs the next
you know their fists fighting in the
yard
you know and I was like oh y'all can
just keep the money when they're just
beating each other's teeth in Jesus we
had the Cason brothers and their mom was
like 28 or something you know and she
was divorced she was a tough chick but
she was never around and Johnny Cash and
Jimmy Castle was bigger I had fist
fights with both of them you know and I
would take five to get in one round
houses I was 90 pounds and and then
Jimmy beat up Johnny was over there and
Joint came out of the kitchen he got
every every sharp knife in the kitchen
he was holding him like this he couldn't
even throw him he goes
and he had like 10 knives
the cast and brothers those are the
other side of the tracks even though we
didn't have a train tracks there you
know mom mama was hornier their mother
was just horrible she was horny oh dude
we had that lady I think I told you the
other night my mom got a dang Dodge Neon
right and it was so nice and my brother
would go my brother and I was my brother
zeph and I would go sleep in it at night
just because it was cool oh it was just
that it had plush interior yeah it had
uh it just smelled like something new
yeah you know we'd be in there God is
smelling just
just smelling as much news oh God and we
just fall asleep in there and then this
lady we had this lady that live a couple
apartments down and she'd always play
she'd be out there one time and she was
getting railed by some guy on the on the
[ __ ] new car on the against the side
of it dude my brother now my brother and
I woke up and this lady was always out
there kind of touching herself and
[ __ ] huffing you know not paint but
something
um and then we just felt the car shaking
dude it's funny to go by people having
sex we run cross country in high school
and this couple's on the trail yeah let
me buy as far as the car my dad had a
British we always had used cars but it
was a Hillman it was a nice British
sedan and my brother Scott the guy who
ran over Pepe
he was like 18. so he went to some
baseball thing hot dog Jamboree and
later on we found out he had 10
Heinekens so he drove the car home he
had had 10 high against and then he got
hungry so he had pink popcorn he had two
big things and I don't know how he made
it home but he came in and he was so
[ __ ] drunk my dad was you drunk so
he's sitting on the bed I was like so my
dad's doing round half lesson right well
he broke his wrist on his skull probably
the first two punches he wore a cast and
we had to say we couldn't say why my
mom's saying you're killing him you're
killing him but he didn't feel anything
so Scott and I were the team we had to
clean up the pink popcorn covered all
over the front of the Hillman the only
thing worse than that is when the whole
neighborhood's toilets backed up in our
downstairs toilet it just started
flowing out because the downstairs
Brothers had just a toilet down there no
sink and started flowing out so we were
in charge so Scott and I were the Bucket
Brigade so it was poo and [ __ ] and water
going out not just y'all's everybody's
all just not ours just the whole
neighborhood it was just not all ours
they just came and it was flowing up and
we're bailing there's Powerball Brad had
a a drill because it was it was starting
to rise up so he was could have
electrocuted himself but he he was
Drilling and then he went under the
house and was drilling holes for the
water to drain and my mom was screaming
too he was under the house drilling
holes for the water drain yeah the
plumbing was blown up well because it
was filling up the room and we were
bailing as fast we can just just like we
were really good athletes at the time we
were fit but just like for hours and my
mom was screaming I'm throwing it out
the window we were throwing it out the
window and we'd even grab [ __ ] and throw
it out the window and we were just just
well buckets are grabbing we got just in
a frenzy because we just we're trying to
stop it if you got a loose-handed dookie
of a stranger I don't know if there's
any other I mean you should have it well
we had every texture that day we had
kind of Milky we had really solids we
had two double solids we had we had
every kind of feces going out that thing
we learned a lot about the human anatomy
and gastrointestinal stuff yeah but
these are all true stories I couldn't
even tell you I mean there's a lot it's
good it's fun these we had some rough
and tumbles you know what I remember
about a lot of people don't remember
like I'll hang out with my best friends
from growing up and they don't remember
a lot of the stuff that happened that's
the interesting thing I'm like well
you're kind of jogging my memory Because
Of You the car and all these things a
lot of people just don't remember it I
don't know if they didn't weren't paying
us enough attention or I think I was
hyper aware as a kid too I think as
comedians you get hyper aware because
you're really alert and sensitive to
what's going on that's good for a
comedian is to be observant and really
be a sensitive instrument I call it yeah
and so it's almost a form of like form
of Asperger's you don't want to look at
the light too much because everything's
so intense you know and uh I just
remembered all of it you know I just
said because it was and there were some
just lazy moments too but there was one
time where I just got incredibly lucky
and it was almost a spooky day at this
cab weird cabin in Montana well they had
a slot machine in there you know it had
all dimes in it and so I started getting
you were a child I was a child I was
like eight Scott was ten I started
hitting jackpots no it's like and then
he'd do it then I kept hitting jackpots
then we were playing poker we had these
chips and I kept getting perfect hands
it was this day
where I was just incredibly lucky for
this day like I couldn't lose couldn't
lose I went back to the little there was
dimes coming out he gets like you know
one Cherry gets a dime like three
cherries so that was kind of a mystical
day you know yeah things when you're
young they have so much like even if you
win you win seven dimes it's like
remember when this happened or oh yeah I
remember we were going to the movies and
we found a busted open Coke machine and
somebody had been trying to rob it and
like Jimmy dope them and they'd ran off
obviously right if money was falling out
and I walked up and there was all this
money and a watch you could see the
robber that had reached in they would
did his watch had come off so suddenly
it had me a nice watch and as much money
as you could think of I loved it that
was my addiction this shoplifting you
know I would go in when I finally got
caught like I had a special billowy coat
and a special secret pocket in the back
and so I I was like in this drugstore
and I've been shoplifting like crazy you
know shopping candy everything I got
this top that you would Spin and I put
it in there I'm on my bike and right as
I was getting away the guy grabbed the
back of it so that my brothers you know
they are the ones who got me into
shoplifting they would stick stuff down
my deviance they would stick stuff down
my pants but then I you know that I was
shamed by that I took the fall they
didn't say we were shoplifting too and
we used to stick stuff down his pants we
taught him how to do it they didn't say
anything they stayed quiet so my dad
came in
and I thought okay here it comes you
know snapped the belt but then he goes
oh Jesus Christ you brought shame to the
family oh but I didn't really feel that
I stopped [ __ ]
I thought come on they were all
shoplifting
well anyway we're halfway through the
podcast yeah we're gonna take a break
and no I'm sorry we've probably done
pretty good how long have we been two
hours oh Jesus for Jesus Christmas man
seriously really yeah I didn't realize
we kept you in here though you put it in
two partners or no we'll do a one-parter
man
um and yeah I wanna I wonder if they'll
let us play a clip from your show do you
think they will
which I mean we're from the weird place
you can play anything we want they
brought a couple Clips yeah I got a clip
you want to play it yeah which one is it
I'll set it up uh you guys were saying
these submarine crew goes back in time
to the pirate ship okay and then they
interact with them and they figure out
they've gone back in time and they go on
a tour of the pirate ship to show them
everything and they go to the brig and
they meet this especially potent
prisoner and the captain McKinley from
1966 is a little thrown by it and this
is their conversation he's behind the
bars okay
are you sure that cell will hold it
I could never break out not with these
balls manifest
now who is this hardly a Thai gentleman
I'm captain McKinley of the United
States Navy
man something
some Stray by you
Lord is that sweet fragrance ass man
it's a deodorant do dog ran
never heard of it huh this guy's
starting to give me the creeps so
there's a little it's you know the
filmic music the sound effects like he's
slapping the bar and the effect on my
voice we played around with that forever
I was doing Hannibal Lecter I was doing
all and then these guys pitched it down
and I said oh God that's the guy that's
our that's our bad guy that's psycho
Bill who is this right here yeah what's
that sweet fragrance I smell uh
deodorant never heard of it you're a
Navy man something strange about you oh
yeah you know it's almost like
somebody's uh just bought a new cat do
we have another one do we have the ant
one or no
yeah I got it okay here is like the guy
who gets the magic power with the globe
these bullish [ __ ] on him he says he
says I'll fight you and I'm an abandoned
lot outside of town then he goes to the
globe and he sees an ant and he puts an
ant on the globe and it's magic Globe so
he drops it on the lot there at and
they're just waiting to fight him and
this giant ant comes out of the sky and
these bullies have to fight the ant oh
there's what there's a piece of it
there's a lot longer but yeah look at
those legs coming out of the sky
[Music]
oh no we gotta find this thing keep your
feet moving boys
ass get the shotgun out of the truck
yes
so they're fighting for their life just
to give you a sound collage that who
made the ant noise they uh they did it
they did effects I did some practical
effects where we we layer so much fun
layered in a ton of effects
we kind of lay down some initial effects
with our just voices and whatnot or find
some stuff on you and then we would send
it out to our to our mixer guy we were
kind of collaborating with and he'd help
us sort of how exciting are the moments
whenever you kind of like okay let's
redo it again but then you realize how
much you raised the bar on it you're
like oh my God that's it yeah that's it
look how much more we can do that's why
you kept doing it and those guys went
downtown with that ant thing
or do you feel like you had were you
afraid to be the you're obviously the
odd person out and there's nothing you
can do about that that's you know but no
you know we all grew up together we had
a whole cut cutting our back fence and
we had a tin can phone and whatnot so
yeah dude we were they were they know
each other he's like a brother from
another mother I mean they're like thick
as thieves and they have so much shared
experience I met Julian when he was
three God what was he like then
he was he was about uh he was pretty
pretty cocky really he had diapers on
but he hadn't no he was just a cute
little kid shirtless probably huh
probably just strolling around the
neighborhood yeah drinking out of a tit
that's [ __ ] as you can get dude and his
dad's from Mississippi so really that
was you know I was I was baptized in
Mississippi oh damn baby that's what's
up yeah
dude I saw uh I used to work over there
and uh I had to paint a fence one time
right with this fellow Big Johnny and he
was a homo erotic guy right and they
didn't you know and he would wear uh big
chains and stuff and he had a big afro
and he would drive on a riding lawnmower
all the time and
he and I had to paint this white fence
and the birds all these uh I think they
were Nightingales maybe we'd come and
try to get into his hair and so my job
while we were painting I had a badminton
racket and just to whack them all day
bro so that was your job yeah we were
out I started painting but by the maybe
about an hour in he couldn't handle the
pressure of the nature so what 60 cents
an hour and you're just whacking birds
with attention oh I was doing pretty I
was getting paid five bucks an hour but
I was out there I probably dude I bet I
took 30 sparrows off that dude's brim
that day man I mean because they his
hair was just wow they wanted a nest in
it but did you wound them and then
they'd fly away or does it really whack
them dead I'd say probably 40 40 50 or
40
not 40 50. 50 50. wow
birds are intense yeah it depends well
the problem with birds is they're coming
out of the sky and you don't know what's
going on up there that's what I find
right we have animals you get a little
bit more you get to they run up you get
the Ambiance about a bird you're like
[ __ ] you know we have some koi fish on
our farm slash Ranch and they're inside
this cement it came with the house but
they built it so like the Bald Eagles or
whatever's up there because most of the
people come over go I can't believe
they're still alive and they're big
they're like 40 pounds and they'll live
to like 100 they will yeah they'll live
way past us they're like vegetables that
float around I mean they go around in
circle on a five foot thing and they're
fascinated for a hundred years but
anyway it said that the the birds
intuitively know they could get them
with their talons is that it but they
wouldn't they don't have enough Runway
to get out because they'd hit the Buddha
statue damn so they're safe for now
they're safe for now yeah be safe for
now I think we all we're all that's all
we all we're all safe uh how do we close
this deal I I this has been so much fun
I really told you a lot of
stuff no look I'm just I think it's
interesting I've heard some about your
life I think it's nice that you're
getting to work on a project that you
know with family obviously family is
something that's been very important to
you and so I think that's super to me
that's really cool man like you know I
talk about doing stuff with my brother
there's a lot of people who'd give
anything to be able to do a job with
their dad no matter what it is you know
and like
um especially to make something like
this that almost anybody could really
make like of course people aren't going
to have no people people make them but
we know that you got it there's a whole
new level you need to go to you can't
just write a script get some voice
actors and add a couple effects right
you need to win the war every moment for
the attention span you need every single
moment that's why we made it kind of
like an album yeah you know rather than
just something to get something else hey
maybe someone will buy it will make a
lot of money yeah you know we actually
said no we want to conquer this space
and those guys who they were riding with
me at the table they were directing me
um they were doing rewrites and they
were doing the editing and they were
stacking the effects and working with
Ben and you know it's just and choosing
music bringing in the music and the
music inspired me yeah you know and the
right scary music for psycho Bill what's
the music and we had that Library so we
we were able to make it filmic as you
can see by these samples oh yeah well it
also does that thing for me it brings
back your imagination that's it suddenly
my imagination has to work and it's
almost excited and I don't mean that any
dad and son could do this or any dad and
family and friends can do this or any
group anybody could you could make
something fun with your family you could
do something with the tools available
you can make cool you can make really
cool stuff yeah but also obviously you
guys are trying to get it at a level out
there where it's like you know you want
to put a piece of art out into the world
and I think it's interesting that you
didn't burn yourself out over the years
so you still have the ver a little bit
of the veracity or concern or whatever
to want to do something like this a lot
of people get burnt I mean there are
people that you know do 20 things that
they don't want to do for years and they
get burnt out you know so by the time
watch The Time Machine with Rod Taylor
obsessed which I showed him as a little
kid and he's possessed by it so art and
music my family with the Beatles and
movies just everything to us making art
uh doing it I like to think that because
of my cross-country and track I've kept
my VO2 max really strong yeah like I
don't think anyone in Hollywood could
hike up a hill with me I don't really
think so if they could but I'm going
past like they're all in the slow lane
so you could beat Neil and easy on his
little well yeah I don't want to pick on
him I'm thinking of you and me mono
Amano I'm looking at 30 years younger
he's got lungs on him does your dad have
some good lungs on him decks
unbelievable wow well I've just never
stopped I need it for my mental health I
love playing the guitar like I do it for
an hour every night making up [ __ ] and I
need the the breaking the sweat with the
pulse I love it so but I do think the
core energy and passion for me and I'm
just surprised I'm it sounds so
self-congratulatory but I care just as
much about this as anything I've done
anything doesn't matter to me when
something was kind of shitty you can
tell if something's popular okay I might
like it but well you can tell by hearing
right you just tell because that it the
amount of layering that went into it and
the amount of sound collage and just
finding cycle Bill and writing the part
and what do they say I want to ask you a
question yeah
blink in your brain when you hear that
voice I could never Escape what do you
picture
um psychobil you mean yeah I picture a
big uh oh you know what he said no well
it kind of wonder if my brain's taking
over I picture uh a little bitty guy
with the biggest wiener you've ever
[ __ ] seen a human tripod I mean he's
got no he has to wear it over his
shoulder in a bag yeah he uses it or
weapon but he doesn't even talk about it
it's just you don't really know that
okay and he has the biggest thickest
darkest mustache you've ever [ __ ] see
that's the thing that is your psycho
bill that's your cycle bill so that you
and you can get out of the prison easy
he could literally just walk through the
bars if you want oh there's stuff that
happens but he stays in there because
it's just it's well things happen in the
storyline there's stuff that happens
with the other Sailors and there's some
illicit stuff that's going on yeah good
so you know that that's the great thing
about this if you're driving around as a
mom with your kids and it's nothing I
can listen to it family and let them
Imagine The Story let them decide what
Captain McKinley looks like or Captain
Jack you know who I worked after my
wife's Irish uncle
am I on a talk like that and we just
call him Captain Jack so all the
characters have some
some reason or some way I found my way
to them there's a character called
smarty Wiggins a pirate and I base it
off this Irish woman Noni who talks sort
of like this but he's the smartest
pirate in the world and he invents the
toilet and he goes I call it a lavatory
because he's a genius pirate but that
was coming from noni's voice God Rest
her soul she went to the Stars God damn
that's what my father used to say all
the time oh really go dude oh damn and
he would like just randomly yeah we'd
wake him up and be like God damn it
it was like all I remember was saying
most of my life dude and then he would
like have some beers he would oh he
would take me to the bar with him and
he'd tell me to go walk down the bar and
come back you know well my dad used to
literally walk down the bar and I'd walk
down and with all the people's glasses
on and stuff walk down and get a beer
for him or just walk down it and come
back you know when you're little It's a
Long Bar you know
yeah you know reaching in and getting a
little popcorn or a snack yeah you're
you know jumping over this glass and you
know it's dark and conversate with
people it's almost maybe that's how I
got on stage first I didn't think about
that well sometimes I go walk the bar
for him down there and the lady would be
down there she'd give me a little
Christmas candy even if it was out of
season she'd have a little cup of
Christmas Canon and he just wanted you
to walk down just to see what it was
just get off his nerves for about 30
seconds oh just go walk around for a bit
yeah go walk down the bar each side
because it's hard to get down the bar if
you walk down the floor it's wide open
but the bar there's deviants you got a
damn [ __ ] pedophile you got a couple
fists fighting there you know you got a
guy picking his nails you know and
giving it to you or whatever
you know you got a lot of them and you
have a great memory you got people to
meet along the way you paid pictures
with your brain because I'm imagining
this bar now oh and imagine 10 year old
Theo Tony padones it was called Tony but
then my dad was like we're gonna ride
we're gonna all right we're gonna head
home and he we'd sit in the car like
we're gonna leave in just a minute and
then he'd [ __ ] fall asleep and I'd
just be [ __ ] sitting there I'm
waiting for him to wake up oh my dad
would when I was in junior I was the
last kid there he'd give me a enema kit
because he was too embarrassed to go buy
one oh oh Jesus Christ Dane this is this
is my best this is how we talk oh could
you give me one of these and it's
something funny because I was buying the
enema kit for him no embarrassment yeah
even though they might be going what you
you you're that constipated you're 18
you weigh 110 pounds Jesus kid but I
know okay just give me the animal kit
Jesus Christ but he he did take us to
the KitKat Club in Idaho falls and it
was illicit it was dark and kind of
nasty your father took in there he took
us in there he couldn't wait to get you
a drink no we were just driving up to
Montana my sister went with my mother on
a plane and so we drove up but this the
bar scene as a young the darkness of it
because when I worked at Holiday Inn as
a busboy and I'd go to or a waiter I'd
go into the bar to get drinks in the
afternoon and then there'd be like a
parent of one of my friends would be in
there just getting blasted he'd see me
and he'd kind of looked down
and then I did room service I waited on
Michael Jackson I waited on Little
Richard he was naked I've waited where
Richard was and did he answered the door
naked it was somewhere around well there
was a man in the bed with sheets over
and he answered the door it seems pretty
gay I think I think it's gay and he goes
have you been to the show because he was
playing the circle Stars you were a
child I was 18 19. you've been to the
show and I I did you know I just I
waited on Richard Pryor waited on
um you know
Carlin waited on rich little stuff like
that and those are whole other stories
but yeah
but anyway so Theo um I think we're okay
man I think we got enough we spent a lot
of time together man well it just flowed
really nice because I do this now so
yeah
this was really fun and easy I enjoyed
it a lot yeah me too man I really did I
mean I kind of broke a sweat a little
bit it's good I think I'm okay I think
it counts as a workout good well just
you get a you know you just sort of get
it's exciting just sharing these stories
and The Way We Were bouncing off each
other because your stuff just keep it
was inspiring me oh thank you because
I'm like a new car the brother the thing
the guy with one toe or whatever it's
like oh man okay oh we had something
kind of like that too yeah so we were we
were kind of hillbillies from the middle
class white suburbs basically up there
in the Bay San Francisco Bay Area yeah I
bet I think it's interesting I think
there's just so many commonalities uh
but I love remembering things from the
past I think it's pretty fascinating I
love imagination and yeah I think stuff
like this is good stuff like um the
weird place is great for people because
yeah it'll help it just to get you to go
especially moms knowing her dads knowing
that they could listen to what their
kids see yeah hey what do your kids
think throw it on you know oh yeah and
then we we have some uh emotionality
like I said in it nothing heavy-handed
but there's some sweetness to it and
earnestness to it and it we were doing
thinking of this before Ted lasso which
I think that struck a nerve too we love
the dark stuff and you know but there's
something about earnestness and
sincerity and we loved going back into
that 60s Vibe and they're all Evergreen
they could play a thousand years from
now if there'll still be submarines and
um so we just love it and um just feel
very lucky was there ever a chance like
looking back on some of your like Prime
days when you were working on SNL and
you got to work with somebody unique
people yeah and in a time when they let
characters really develop and yeah and
reoccur and you had your catchphrase
yeah it was so it was so much fun
um was there ever a chance you guys
would try to get back to I've always
wondered why didn't like five or six of
the guy eyes
say hey let's do this again let's just
make our own thing and do it it's you
know it you see that's an outside of
perspective you know no I know and you
always think oh but then you're kind of
like how do you get back to sketch you
know me doing these voices and
improvising these rhythms was exercising
that same idea and there's a freedom
without an audience you know you don't
want to be indulgent but you can also
step outside yourself but yeah it's a
magic thing that's why spade and I's
podcast is popular it's a reality show
the people will laugh and we'll have a
good time but there's an emotional
underpinning to that shared story of
getting this incredible lucky break
you're with your friends or I call them
your band mates you're all getting a
little money you're getting a little
famous and you're all doing it together
and you're live in Rockefeller Center
Way up in the sky in the middle of the
night and there's horses and dwarfs on
the show and people are juggling and
you're falling down and all kinds of
[ __ ] it going on and so it's something
that's a it's a fever dream kind of in a
way yeah but getting back to it is is
very tough there's other ways to do it
you know
um I think I had a podcast a while back
where I was doing long form riffs it was
called fantastic it's still out there
where I would just take flight of
fancies and go for 10 minutes because
that's what I would do backstage Kevin
and I would do Hans and fronds for like
an hour yeah you're a loser we were just
cocking that voice for an hour you found
good moments yeah and then we'd have to
repeat it on but our best moments we
would just fall and giggling and you
know just by you you know the moment you
can't that moment it's so nice when
Kevin said and if you don't think we're
properly pumped up men you know the
defensiveness of Hans and Franz we could
very easily come to your house stretch
the flap of your back into the shape of
a rope ladder so you could crawl down
into the sewer because that's where
losers live to me it's poetry it may be
my favorite rhythms and the guys who
never lift anything they're terribly
wounded terribly insecure they have this
stupid show and they're just trying to
get back at imaginary enemies they think
the audience doesn't think they're Macho
and I could very easily you're lucky
your buttocks are like marshmallows
you're lucky I don't have a campfire
here don't undo your belt you might
cause a flabber lunch you put tell your
muscles are so flabby I like to shape
him in a bowl and put them under the put
you on the Christmas tree you know it
just gets into madness so Kevin and I
love that I was sort of would have been
happy if that movie had come to fruition
a very funny movie Conan O'Brien Roberts
Michael me and Neal and wrote together
Hans and Franz the girlie man dilemma so
but anyway Life's good you know Life's
good man you're staying creative you get
into uh
you didn't have a family and be a real
human in a family that's awesome
um thanks yeah yeah my wife and I are
just incredibly regular people doing
doing regular things there's there's an
enviable thing when I see people who can
really take joy and doing regular things
yeah without being in their head just
going to a matinee watching a movie I'm
having popcorn man this is great I'm
putting I'm putting some raisinets in
the popcorn you are I'd say to Scott
what are you gonna get my brother's got
movies here everything yeah and we were
big into movies we liked a movie we'd
see it five times oh dude I remember
going to Pink Cadillac it was it was
playing somewhere in my grandmother's
town and I went over there what year was
that I don't know damn I don't know saw
it over and over again yeah oh I just
remember eating so much [ __ ] candy
vomiting in the bathroom and going back
and watching more
we go to matinees but you would go at 12
and come out at five oh yeah any crazy
coming out in the light it was so light
again outside yeah and you're in there
watching Audie Murphy Westerns back to
back you might get a sucker and nurse
that or if you're a big hunk you just
suck on that you had to last all that
time it was like you could bring a can
of beans or 50 cents because if they
were having a Salvation Army thing there
bring some soup and get in for a five
hour matinee even though we're a
generational part there's so many things
we have in common things it just uh you
know you know maybe we were the original
Hillbillies of of San Carlos parents
from Montana you know gristle and Dale
baked goods and everyone loved to come
to our house [ __ ] and balls babe oh I'm
caught I'm only caulk he's only boss
when you put us together you got Coke
and battles yeah all right we should
Mike drop it on that yeah we'll do it
there Dana Carvey thanks for your time
thank you loved it enjoyed it peace out
[Music]
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life
[Music]